Wow E great moves up hello everybody
we're back St Street podcast off the
rails January 17 the
year I see in the document it says 23
but that is not true it is we have moved
on Time Marches forward it stops for No
One 24 24 you which means we're
getting older and that
sucks sucks does anyone else have enst
about I mean I don't have that much enst
about aging but like you always say it
like that which whatever we've discussed
it it's it's fine to say it that way you
you were right so then so then what's
the nobody cuz nobody says it that way
it's very theatrical so we looked into
it and the way I say it is okay it's
totally okay it's just not many people
say it like that so I just wonder where
you pick well not there's not many
people like me that's true fortunately
congratul you have age angst that's it
is that okay to say it that way Dan can
I get your
approval yeah I mean of course like like
anybody yeah sure it's not crazy but
like as I close in on 40 40 sucks
because then you're just 10 years away
from 50 and 50 is like old once you're
50 then you're 10 years from 60 and 60
is like you're retiring s I've been in a
existential crisis since I turned 25 oh
Zach you're the youngest though how old
are you 25 26 oh yeah you're getting old
yeah you're getting up there over the
hill you're in your 20s man don't worry
about it chill no but like I'm like a
couple years from being 30 and then like
might as well be 40 and then it be
50 and then you're dead well okay let me
put it let me put it this way for you
Zach you're
26 you've lived a long beautiful life in
fact probably five first years you don't
even remember so you can write those off
yeah you've had a long full life in 21
years G and shave off 5 d double that
double that and you're still only 42
that's two lifetimes you've lived and
you're still only 42 and that's your
age yeah and I'm
what's the point man like we just
what's the point what's the point what
is the point let's wrap it up just like
you know these thoughts why are we here
what are we doing you know just been
it's been me up oh o o o is
right so what is the point what what
have you determined in your in your mind
I'm still trying to figure that
out really you have any leads
[Laughter]
nah in Clues I hear the answer is
14 the answer is 14 14
pages I I haven't heard that I've heard
that the answer is 42 it's 42 is that
what you're going for then yeah 42 like
your age you're right there you're right
sweet spot the joke of course being Zach
is we can get the answer but we don't
know what the question is
is and I don't think we ever will for
you you know our we're just here to to
live baby we're just here to live you
know we're just space dust they got to
put our peek our heads up for a moment
and then go back go back to nothing you
people are not thinking about the
question exactly thank you Andrew get
it um anyways today's episode is
sponsored by stamps.com we have a great
episode today
uh Sean Stevens friend of the show I am
rectangular amang he actually sent us a
video during our live show we really
wanted to get him in the studio to
perform but he was traveling to Mount
Kilimanjaro with his
family to um announce I guess at the top
of the mountain it's funny he says he
did that to promote his music and I was
like bro just just to be real with you
comeing on to our live show would have
done a lot better you know although
although Silver Lining he traveled South
Africa to visit his mom and they got
kidnapped which turned into
international news not silver well
silver well that's some good promo from
the aspect of promoting your music yeah
strictly from that mindset siloing it
from from the horrifying experience that
that must have been yeah it was great PR
yeah
siloed anyway he's and anyway it sounds
horrible I'm kidding but it sounds
horrible and scary he's calling in to to
talk about his experience
there I am kidnapped youer I am a
prisoner ah oh yeah you go help help
help I am a prisoner
help anyway it's it's not
funny well the good news is they're all
f totally fine they are all totally fine
everybody's okay except for I'm sure the
uh the lasting trauma of going through
an experience like that is probably but
physically at least they are physically
they're okay yeah Alexander thank you
for the Don he says the point of life is
to be happy and live life the way you
want to cringe is dead wait what cringe
is dead nothing
matters cringe is dead what they're
saying like nii or I'm not quite sure
what that's meant to is that like God is
dead like cring is dead baby live with
Reckless abandon no cringe dance like
nobody's cringing at
you I believe is the
saying yeah we' got that and so much
more here today um still catching up by
the way did we get the thermometer uh a
or not yet it's coming right now oh good
order so you guys heard about the
Stanley Cups that are causing people to
lose their damn Minds that like
apparently this person's car set on fire
and then it still had ice inside of it
so we're going to put that to the test
here today oh it still had ice
apparently yeah there's a video that's a
new detail I have not heard I just heard
that it survived the fire which it's
like okay great the ice cubes survived
the fire okay now it makes a little more
sense why I went viral so we're going to
have a good we're going to have to put
this thing through the ringer a bit
maybe get a bucket of hot water put it
in there set it on
fire uh put in the dishwasher with the
ice closed that's a test that's a test
we're going to have a thermometer we're
going to keep checking the temperature
and see if it's all that yeah that's
coming up
um ninja gets a low taper
fade all right dude all
right imagine
[Applause]
n we'll getting all of that actually
so yeah we'll get into that but at the
top of the show we got to First
acknowledge that yes it is true we're
not here on Monday to the disappointment
of
many we took MLK junr day off and if you
complain you are racist I just want to
you to I just want you to know that at
this point in
time but yeah we took off MLK day I'm
trying to you know be good about U
observing the national holidays for the
crew so that they can live you know
happy balanced lives and participate in
society I know everyone at home is like
I don't get that day off you should you
should why don't wait don't they need to
well school gets it off and federal
employees all get it off and a lot of a
lot of people do get it off if you're
working like a standard kind of whatever
desk job you don't get that day off or
maybe you know what they're they're the
it's the restaurante teers it's the
server oh if you work in a restaurant
you do not but you get time and a half
at least right no hell no it's so normal
we live Society was a law for MLK day no
was a national holiday any national
holiday I maybe I'm wrong about that I
don't know got fact check that yeah
anyway I don't remember well I had a lot
of wages stolen when I worked in a
restaur part of the game baby yeah
little wage theft ain't no thing more
than a little I've gotten since since I
worked yes at CPK sorry I had to bring
it up but since work you worked at CPK
yeah yeah yeah since working there I
have um had three different class action
uh lawsuit settlement checks sent to me
from stolen wages from
who all from all from California Pizza
Kitchen what anything interesting in the
amounts you got uh no every all three of
them were like $300 to $600 something oh
that's I mean it was that's a nice check
yeah and I'm sure what was actually
stolen was way more than that we never
got breakes or anything working like
just flat that's crazy that a huge
corporate chain is doing all that they
would make us sign uh break waivers
which I always refuse to sign they made
you sign those yeah they would uh they
would have the hosts go around to all
the employees and sign off that you were
saying it's okay that I don't break take
a and what happen if you don't sign it
nothing I never signed it well I I did
it first and then I like realized what
was going on I'm like I'm not
signing this got Su for the one thing
when I was working at restaurants that
we had was breakes you go and you take a
break not at my restaurant you have a
cigarette you Ketch so sorry we got to
go to
break wow well anyway we took the day
off I guess people were angry because
some people were angry because we took
three weeks off and then we come back in
of the hood spot to take a day off I'm
so
angry well I'll say this I'm glad that
you guys care enough to be
mad and also I'll also say this
if you want this show to continue in the
long run you got to let us you know live
our
lives uh here you go from the
California uh government there is
nothing in state law that mandates an
employer pay an employee a special
premium for work performed on a holiday
Saturday or Sunday other than the
overtime premium required for work in
excess of eight hours in a work day or
40 hours work week so no no extra
you show up at work yeah the that's
in California or yeah
wow that's a thankless business man show
up and work and work harder yeah you
tell them
Joe okay but anyway yeah so sorry about
that uh actually I was thinking about
taking today off National or not
National but holidays today let's see
did you know that today is um National
lose the jet lag day yo for real that's
important what is
that let's see January 17th yeah I was I
have so many reasons not to work today
so you guys should be all very grateful
that I came in but we've got Museum
selfie day oh dude let's go to Getty yo
let's go yo hot buttered rum
day who's deciding this Benjamin
Franklin day that's a that's a it's
pretty big cause for celebration Benny
boy Benny boy Cable Car day National L
what the is National lose the jet
lag day give me a break that's
dumb that's the firstep at the same time
ditch New Year's resolution day we we're
we're over it amen it's 17 days in we're
out can we get a national H3 podcast
today yeah that's today
actually we don't get it off what the
hell National Charlotte day shout out to
all the Charlottes out there in the
audience give it up national boot leers
day we love them folks we love all the
boot lers out there don't we mhm sure do
yeah national hot buttered rum day we we
covered that one but that that is good
we'd like to revisit that one day yeah
well anyway so so be thankful that we're
here today
okay what a hero also want to give a
shout
out to AB and Lena who took some heat
during our time off they posted a video
uh titled I'm pregnant it was just
titled pregnant yeah oh just pregnant
just pregnant yeah which you know is
pretty high level clickbait let's be
real there was no truth to it right no
it was uh in regards to a meme we have
on stream but uh what's the meme Welcome
to our apartment tour hold on Sor sorry
I'm just pulling it up so you go ahead
what's the meme what's the meme well I
here's the photo too which doesn't help
this is the photo you guys
chose oh boy I mean I'm not rubbing her
stomach or something well she's not she
just found out she's pregnant yeah I can
see it in her eyes yeah well I want but
how happy you guys are before we get
into it I do want to apologize to people
I I don't know there so many times
working here like I I I just feel like
uh an idiot from Dearborn and that's
probably because I am because like I
don't know these things as soon as you
know people tell me they're offended I
apologize I change the title but uh you
don't know that people don't like
clickbait click we do every day I me
they don't have clickbait in Michigan
yeah I mean listen we we all we all uh
life's it's a it's hit and misses it's
gutters and Strikes that's what we do
here you know what I mean well I mean
the people that explained why it
offended them like sincerely I feel bad
that's horrible why what did they say
well just that they you know they've had
fertil fertility issues and their own
problems and so seeing that uh Trier
them okay that listen that's a whole
another thing to me the reason at large
people are upset is just because you're
playing with their emotions so heavy cuz
when they so happy for you yeah they get
so happy they're like you know oh he's
they're having a baby that's so exciting
we're so happy for you well yeah there's
a few groups of people that watch those
people I feel bad for too but a lot of
the people who commented that it's like
those were people on stream who like we
told the title ahead of time were like
all
right no one mentioned it being a
problem so I don't know it just flew
over my head well when I went to the
comments it was all like I'm so happy no
body watched the video everyone
was just like I'm so happy we so happy a
lot of those people were probably the
ones from stream that I'm referring to
that I mean of course there were some
that were sincerely Happ so all your
audience members are a bunch of
degenerates huh I guess so they
definitely don't watch this show then so
in the opening of the video you can see
immediately that it was a joke although
a bad one let me see let me see let me
click it oh you guys why' you get age
restricted oh we got cuz we got Mass
reported no but like but then you okay
did you dispute it I did dispute it um
did it get did they answered the dispute
yet yeah but they didn't give me a
reason why I'm thinking maybe because
there's like cold Sparks in it and it
looks like fireworks inside the house
but there's cold Sparks so oh cuz I was
thinking about it yesterday like oh that
could be a dangerous act maybe I could
ask my YouTube guy I'm kind of curious
sure that's I have something to tell you
let's see what happened here what's that
I didn't want to say it earlier in front
of my brother and sister-in-law oh God
cuz they're so sick in that jeep by the
way thank you this is a this was a old
clip from an IRL stream we did in
summertime but yeah it's so spacious in
there it is I love it it's nice thanks
I'm
pregnant is this a this is a real prank
that happened or what yeah I mean chat I
was in the the bathroom at this Best Buy
and Lena was waiting in the car talking
to chat and they're like oh when he
comes back tell him you're pregnant it
was just like a off thing whatever okay
so you didn't know about this no I
didn't know about it I came in and then
just walked out when she told me
okay and how did that make you feel
Lena I I didn't really care I mean it
was a joke to begin with so that's why
I'm laughing here after my husband
walked out after I just told him I'm I'm
pregnant when you say it like that well
some comments said I can't believe
people who walk out after being told
that you're not going to see a lot of
the bad comments cuz I I deleted them I
didn't want Lena to see them because
they were
horrible also it's not the first time
this was brought up on stream I get
asked almost every single day when am I
going to get pregnant either by like
chat or my family so for me and I don't
know if anyone knows like I mean they
don't know if I'm trying or what the
case is so I didn't really think of it
in that way and now I realize why it
might hurt some people for that I'm so
so sorry you know um but now now the
question's on the table now we get to
ask every
day you guys open the Pandora's Boxx
when you say so do you guys want
kids uh yeah some people told us we're
going to have bad karma now though
because we this that's that's cruel
that's cruel to say stop don't say that
all this pregnancy
um uh Superstition is it's all it's all
really nasty like people say you know we
and Ela we've we've announced every time
when Ela when we found out she was
pregnant she was pregnant and in in I
guess Jewish tradition or Israeli
tradition they say it's extremely bad
luck to announce it before the first
trimester yeah and uh you know they get
in your head but don't listen to the
superstitious you know that's
why we have the the hand that stops the
evil eye right the evil we don't believe
in Superstition so I drape myself and
evil eye
hands yeah I don't know if it's cultural
or like I said because we're from
Dearborn we didn't even consider I think
because we thought because we're talking
about ourselves and it wasn't like
something like oh we lost the baby oh
God bro I don't know again I'm not
saying I was right but I'm just trying
BR if you click bait that I might have
to fire
you that would be crazy that would be
crazy yeah I mean every time we go home
Lena's family's like what are you guys
waiting for you know so what are you
guys waiting
for well for December when ad revenue's
up nice my
boy all right comedy is as someone said
the last line of defense in our society
so yeah we say in the comedy world we
say we're the last line of defense I
understand people being annoyed because
it's like playing with the emotions but
eh it's not that you know what I mean we
listen how many times we you got get got
to give us a shot here you know what I
mean we're out here we're trying our
best we're pregnant we're not pregnant
who
knows
you
know it's a learning experience we know
better now yeah literally I'm doing
fertility treatment and Ethan and E
being so open about it having a third
baby boy gives me hope okay good luck
out there Anna appreciate you get out
there yeah anyway that was kind of an
interesting little Wrinkle in the the
whole Saga yeah I I think CU I premiered
it too it gave people time to talk about
it before seeing the video Oh that's oh
that's probably where all the comments
came from because then it was like on
you know hate reddits and all that I
thought it was on hate reddits Oh you
mean like The Usual Suspects yeah I
didn't I didn't I didn't even go to our
Reddit so I can't even imagine what
those I didn't see that much I didn't
see that much for you guys on R
Reddit
personally yeah I don't know but I
didn't know it was going to show the
title and the thumbnail already I
thought I was going to say premiering a
video and whatever time so yeah I think
that really screwed me as well well
there it is they are not pregnant but
they will be
soon I'm extrapolating from their
cryptic answers they will be soon
everybody let Lena's mom
know whenever they are I cannot wait to
meet that baby yeah yes yes we got to
have kids days and y'all got to get
to work oh my God so true I'll put it on
the list I need to I need to have a baby
did I mention that my um my
sister-in-law is pregnant did I mention
that on the show no yes they just found
out like a month ago that my brother
sister-in-law yeah are pregnant I didn't
hear about that so that's really that
was really a great news because then the
cousins are going to be really close in
age which is really nice oh that's great
but um butum
buum yeah she's having a horrible time
the first month she's like so sick oh
okay it's like really bad she had to go
to the hospital and get an IV damn from
throwing up a lot just throwing gr up
not being able to eat it's really tough
for some people Jesus really
tough I think you'll be fine though Lena
you you generally you just handle things
well you know what I mean I thank you
ela's the same way it's just like
nothing really bothers her for me I'm
just worried because I don't really have
any help out here like my family so
right yeah that's a big it's a big um
concern would your mom ever come out and
stay with you guys for a little bit yeah
she says that and then also that's her
declaration every time and then okay her
other thing is when I say like I'm busy
I have work she says okay like you can
just send the baby to me I'll watch the
baby what does that mean like male like
FedEx I literally will FedEx me the baby
every time we visit that's what she says
I'll come out there I'll stay out there
well that's a good offer and frankly
because she's so persistent you got to
use that to your advantage but she's
already taken care of three babies now
she babysits every day yeah my nieces
and nephews yeah but they're not
newborns they going have to defend for
themselves for a little bit bit are they
are newborns no there some of them are
newborns yeah I'm not even talking about
the older ones yeah oh I'm like you have
like eight grandkids I mean not like
you're short of any well clearly your
guys is more um special I guess more
important Lena is her favorite daughters
or her trophy daughter if you will
trophy daughter that's what AB says
that's what everyone says ask her
siblings she says it sometimes
too so anyway there it is uh we we we we
had a whole tumultuous ride there but
congratulations congratulations
apologize again I forgive you you guys
understand where I'm from like it's a
completely different world there's a guy
in our heard of clickbait yeah I was hey
where I come from we about babies all
the time bait you're talking about a
holid here dear Michigan come on don't
push do you should have seen Tik Tock in
De and that was wild people legit
just stole what does that mean they
would just take like people singing and
pretend to sing over it there's a whole
Dearborn Tik Tok huh so there's a whole
Dearborn Tik Tok Community there's
there's a Dearborn Community for
everything as why oh interesting so all
kinds of Deerborn videos just show up on
your feed once you like when I live
there that's interesting yeah I saw this
video of Salt Bay this dude pisses me
off man get a load of this con
man I watch this whole thing I wasn't
quite sure I understood all right well
I'll break it down for you as a as a
steak cooker myself let me break it down
for you Dan first of all it's covering
the gold the gold is so dumb it's
so dumb so he's cutting it
that's fine whatever you know what I
mean it's a whole he's got a whole
Tender Loin so let's it's all dumb let's
cut it up into little uh medallions
marbling looks pretty good actually on
that
um but
so first of all the way he throws these
all on the grill is absolutely obscene
you cannot there's you don't stack
steaks you can't crowd them like that
you have to give each one space to sear
and Sizzle this is this is an obscene
way to cook and what looks to be very
beautiful
meat um this is probably the worst way
ever seen to cook a steak in my life and
he's going to boil it in butter okay
which again is seems crazy to me maybe
this is something that I've not been
exposed to but that's just a mountain of
meat and butter now here's the problem
this man goes from handling raw meat and
he's in there he's handling that
mhm to to touching bread with his dirty
gloves and and look what he does for
them he tears it up like he's doing
something this man tears the bread look
look how he pinched it all the
fluffiness is gone that dude touched
bread with raw meat gloves just for that
you ever watch a bar rescue you
ever see that show John Tapper no dude
that show's John Tapper that
sh's awesome man what reminded
you about it he calls him out for doing
that type of like you should watch
it oh la cross contamination yeah that's
like his big no no number one it's crazy
yeah it's like cooking 101 and this guy
apparently he's in the business business
of just handling raw meat and John
Taffer he's more hardcore than
like obviously for TV but it's he's more
hardcore than Gordon Ramsey like he
just annihilates him he also
just what's it called Bar Rescue I'll
check that out yeah resc it's so up your
alley you got to see this guy the
greatest show you've probably seen him
in like memes and oh I've never
seen him he's a demon
huh I love John tord dude goat these
whole they call it screen okay one
second they call it Bar Rescue it's
probably more like bar
Holocaust like the way that Jordan
Ramsey cuz I've seen all that like
the the hotel one the restaurant one he
comes in there and destroys them he
ruins their lives and he gets
them he gets some like a new stove or
something to make up for it and then
almost I'd say like 60 70 80% of the
time out of business within like a few
months or they just reverted everything
and went back that's probably the case
with this guy it he's bar gapo totally
yeah bar gapo totally yeah it's good oh
okay good I got to check it out it's
aw you have to you have to watch
the pirate episode that is the most
legendary one the uh chat's big time uh
backing us up on this too everybody's oh
how did I not know about this guy
he's the goat dude yeah so um
you know it's like you can't if you are
mismanaging a restaurant either you
can't cook you're a bad manager you have
no business sense you can't Gordon
Ramsey is not going to fix any of that
you're just in the wrong Biz people you
know what I mean he's got one where he
tries not Bar Rescue but Gordon Ramsey
where he tries to flip the restaurant in
24 hours yeah and and how did it go I
don't think very well cuz every I don't
know if you do this every time when I
watch one of these I Google the name of
the restaurant to see if it went out of
business right pretty much always yeah
it's kind of iconic like
that but um there it is and then like I
guess people think oh it's good
publicity no it's not nobody's going to
want to eat there I guarantee it when he
comes and looks you walk through fridge
and you've got like year old rotten
chicken and sludge like nobody wants to
eat that and you're like
microwaving Costco bot pies and no
okay
hey
apparently this is his kill death ratio
here that's that's actually pretty good
is it that's for John Taffer yeah almost
50% actually survive how long cuz the
thing is almost all of them are like
they're dog enough that they're
close to going out of business so if
he's actually rescuing close to half on
the show over how long over how long uh
it's just all this is as of 2024 so this
is just like a rolling total I think the
show's been on since 20 that's pretty
good that is pretty good I agree half
well certainly there'd be a percentage
of them that we're going to keep it
going regardless and a lot of them are
probably just getting more Deb and
getting more you see the show though a
lot of them are are just in pretty dire
I wish we could you could send me a
clip I probably get claimed into a like
some of some of the booze in the bar
have like like bugs in it oh my
goodness like it's it's gnarly I've seen
High L if those numbers are accurate he
he's genuinely good Beyond it being
entertaining which it is well I feel
like a bar is easier to save than like a
hotel or resta restaurant cuz it's like
what how you up a bar you just pour
drinks clean the glasses pour the
drinks too A lot of them are places that
are bar and grill so it's more of like a
restaurant some of them are I don't know
so this this isn't from the actual show
this was one that was very famous where
it was a pirates bar that he turned to
like a corporate type area and then when
he left they burned down everything that
he brought and then they they were like
singing like Pirates again they're like
they burned his cuz they didn't
like him yeah cuz they so this video is
epic but there's copyright music in it
but they like shoot up the sign and then
they end up closing yeah I want to see
that's awesome good for you guys that's
real pirate right there h m yeah
that was his corporate sign hand me the
rum there bucko let's go get us some
let's go everything right let's go rape
some
women that's what the Pirates did I
guess let's go plunder and rape y'all
thanks not that not that funny thanks
anyway the Salt
Bay I got questions Man Dan this is you
right in this commercial in the Mega Man
commercial that is me
what okay cuz I was like hold on that's
that's probably not Dan but then I
watched it watch I believe an
11-year-old Dan s so how did this all
happen uh it's a way less interesting
story than you than uh you'd think my
cousin worked for Capcom in their
marketing department and they needed
people to do testimonials for this
commercial they were making did they she
knew I play Mega Man uh no I don't think
so that see that's crazy how they do
that it was at some like event at like
an arcade or something I it was a long
time ago it's very hazy but uh but wait
but I was happy to do it I love Mega Man
still do that's how they get you though
that's how they get free labor out of
children yeah now they exploit me you
got they have money yeah they got ccom
money that's Street Fighter dude break
Cat Marvel versus Capcom not your fault
wait Capcom owns a whole bunch of
they're massive Capcom uh I yeah I mean
they're pretty big I think they own
other let me see yeah they have a ton of
sub um companies too I believe they're
actually still pretty big in like the
arcade space too
like a lot of uh arcade cabinets and
stuff are made by Capcom Jesus yeah they
got Resident Evil they got
uh Street Fighter which is still
super popular so yeah pay up yeah I need
one another one of those class actions
there it is so but how did they come
across this was this ever like a paid or
a commercial somewhere that's what I was
wondering how the did they find it
is the user that posted this what are
you doing watching television ads from
graphic is so cool it just has
everything
that they put it together like a big ass
commercial though they probably did run
this on TV why else no it did it did
this was dude that's crazy they didn't
pay you that's up hit him up did
you give you like free games or anything
um well my cousin oftentimes did hook me
up with stuff because she was working in
the industry she left the video game
industry a long time ago but can see why
exploting children but
but um yeah I uh I guess I never really
thought about it they probably should
have paid all those
kids oh yeah they were just kind of they
were like farming these interview they
had like a station it was some event or
something and they were just like
farming interviews they were having kids
just like come through and sit down and
they would just ask them a couple
questions about Mega Man or whatever
that's and so I popped in and did
it and uh I made the cut cuz I can I
sayal you crush a natural dude let's
see you go like this do all that I have
grown up with me man I have grown up
that's it it sounds it feels very true I
have I have grown up with Mega Man yeah
you didn't say you like it frankly I
still got it folks you know uh say the
line say the
line grab that Zach if you haven't yet
you got it yeah I think your cousin
probably pulled strings to slip you in
there
no I suppose she may I don't think she
had that much influence you think they
you made the cut with that comment I did
grow up with Mega Man I you are you
questioning the Integrity of the Capcom
marketing team I just accused them of
stealing labor from kids they're going
to pick the best
performances I have grown up with Mega
Man yeah yeah I can see that's that's a
really pertinent Tes nailed it dude yeah
so hold on I got to call you out scroll
up the graic so cool it just you what
what yours BB yours BB the user that
posted this yeah I I need I need answers
how the did you find how the
did you spot that did you connect that
that that was
me yeah message one of the mods I'm
actually I'd like an answer on that I'd
like to
know is there any answers in the in the
comments uh yeah it's 100% him pit pat
says his parents were involved in
animation nice find Z needs to for drop
I have grown up with Mega
Man that is a good drop that's a deep
danl
man that's awesome shout out to Mega Man
especially Mega Man X by the way bro why
didn't you tell Super Nintendo err games
those are my goats how why didn't you
tell us this earlier that you were
aown you were a full-blown Mega Man this
morning uh AB was like Dan are you in
this Mega Man commercial and that was
the
first like it all like came back to me
in a Flash I was like yeah I was in a
Mega Man thing like 25 years ago Olivia
and Lena lost their minds I couldn't
believe you were a child one time you
know he kind of sounded like an adult
your voice was my voice was very deep in
that sounds deeper than it is now
somehow maybe I was overcompensating um
I had grown up with it would have been
it would have been in like early middle
school so how old are you in like sixth
or seventh grade like 12 yeah gu
I would say it probably was clip yeah
you're hitting it then yeah I played
Mead what I grew up with mega
bad um well that's fun that's exciting
new bit of lore there for
everybody should I we need to do a poll
okay cuz we keep talking about Panera
Bread yesterday on the member stream I
ordered a Panera Bread lightning heart
attack um lemonade
yeah how was it supercharged
supercharged exactly I'm about to
supercharge your
heart um do we have the defibrillators
here if I do we drink that uh my
cardiologist told me no he specifically
said be careful with caffeine so I'm
going to drink two larges back to back
no your doctor said be careful CA no no
my heart is in beautiful condition wow
gorgeous
um
so I was on the member stream yesterday
ordering from Panera and I was curious
do they still sell this I mean two
people now died yep allegedly at least
in connection with this lemonade after
two one is a fluke two is like a pattern
people be dropping dead but also it's
kind of fire marketing I thought to
myself because there's probably a lot of
people at home thinking like Dam that's
a drink that's going to pet me up in the
morning and I'm one of those people in
fact so so my thought was
this and I I'm someone that's not
affected by caffeine almost at all at
all
um so I'm thinking this two larges
backto back during this show and to see
if I
die cuz I've been wanting to try it so
anyway I ordered it yesterday and then
they they didn't bring the damn thing
man oh that's what happened they didn't
bring it I'm so pissed dude Panera
up my order every time dude
me and Ela ordered they didn't bring any
of my have have you switched up the
location's Imagine the One by my house
is the same as the one near the office
your order here got messed up too didn't
it didn't we order once and it was all
super delayed it took forever oh man
okay I'm notna I'm not going to die on
this hill defending Panera Bread I will
honestly I will die on
it let's do a pull let's be real well
let's see do you guys want want to see
me Crush two lightning lemonades and me
crush a soup I would love that who wants
to see Olivia crush a soup literally
it's the it's the year of soup for real
for real can I be real yeah I had some
of ela's uh it was like a cream of
mushroom chicken soup WIP with wild rice
good soup is different I drank
every drop of that bread bowls too bread
Panera it's pretty
amazing um you you started this with
let's throw up a pole yes what is the
pole should I get should I try to drink
I her no no no should I kind of should I
get should you drink two of the
caffeinated drinks Ride the Lightning
it's not should I ride the lightning I
don't think it's enough my hoodie man
realistically R the lightning baby well
both of these people had pre-existing
conditions but I I what I really want to
see is if I feel anything cuz I I'm
telling you guys I I don't feel caffeine
like it doesn't work for my body I don't
know why my whole life and I feel this
um does anyone else feel that way I'm
with you 100% I get sleepy from it
sometimes me too if anything that's what
I think immediately from caffeine yeah I
yeah I'm I'm diagnosed with ADHD and
that's like a big thing is caffeine puts
you to sleep sometimes I don't think I
have or maybe I do I don't know whatever
that causes I that's a thing that exists
with me I literally will take a shot of
espresso I'll be out in a second why
does coffee I I've I've searched this
before and it always says something like
ad80 but I feel like it's got to be more
than that you don't you don't seem to
have anything like that love I mean not
diagnosed but I think I defin you're
saying well
listen ADHD is a real medical issue
people are these days are like oh yeah I
it's I like Tik Tok I have
ADHD no I have like um I get annoyed
yeah I'm pretty sure I do but since I'm
not diagnosed I'm not going to you seem
pretty chill like during the episodes
you're focused no no he has like 50
things going on on the screen at really
yeah I do a lot of things also love
won't play any video game that isn't uh
just non-stop instant action I'm killing
people I'm back flipping like we anytime
you try and get them to play anything
that's like slightly chilly like this
shit's way too boring it just doesn't
stimulate me yeah okay well I do not
have ADHD I'm a of mental
health uh the pole didn't work I see
everybody saying it's broken and yeah it
actually has zero VES so this says uh I
asked why does coffee make me sleepy
caffeine can block the effects of adenos
sign which is what makes you feel alert
after your morning cup of coffee however
once the caffeine wears off your body
may experience a buildup of Ado sign and
that hits you all at once that's that
that's see that that's not that's not
true it's like immediately I just just
feel
sleepy so the poll was nobody's
addressing this I I've been diagnosed
with ADHD I feel the same way as Olivia
okay hold on there's no way that we have
three people with diagnosed ADHD and
well you just we've been learning things
on this show we learned Monday or less
Monday that half of our audience is
autistic so that's so true the numbers
they're higher than you think you took
an Autism uh quiz on the stream
yesterday I think it's time for ADHD
quiz to do definitively diagnose you
that's not how that works shut up Jake
do little ass I've been booked for
like um appointment with a a thing
whatever it's called specialist to find
out but I missed the appointment like 10
or 15 times like a kid you not throw
that's one of the first tests that's
something that my therapist and I work
on is being on time and um missing
things because I get anxious even going
there yep it's bad okay so the same same
website that I just sent you all right
I'll do that but according to this
similarly to autism
2.6% of adults have ADHD so we are
really defying all
statistical possibilities here in the H3
podcast um let me take a
test let's get to the bottom of this I
passed the Autism test by the way if
anyone not I passed I could give you my
girl's name not kind of test what do you
mean diagnostic that's not how that
works who was it that said full-blown
autism we were making fun of RFK oh yeah
RFK we are watching him on how's podcast
who by the way I'm going on a show
tomorrow he's doing a live show again
how and he text he said he wants me to
come on again when did when did that
go he asked a couple weeks ago oh but I
can't say not to Howe he's does he does
so much for us that's
true so that what be be doing but yeah
RFK yesterday on how show said he
referred to people with with severe
autism as full-blown autism fullblown
baby like they've got like full-blown
like AIDS or
something the a the the autism has fully
matured he is fully blown
out question one I find it difficult
finishing a task or
project
yeah Dan says yes what do you say yes
based on I would say
sometimes you would disagree with that
Dan I guess it depends on how we're
defining a task or a project is your
task to say get through this story no in
a reasonable amount of time without
getting distracted and going off on 10
different tangents in the process no I
think a task is like I'm going to throw
up the trash and then you throw up the
trash mhm instead of getting like
sidetracked on side missions and stuff I
do a lot of side missions yeah yeah I'm
going to say sometimes okay you know
yourself I find it difficult to organize
myself or a task I definitely cannot
organize my life at all so I'll
say I'll say very often yes I find it
difficult to remember appointments Lena
what do you
think you haven't really had to
remember but if I did but if I did if
you did well you remember that you have
that thing tomorrow yeah cuz I was
texting with him yesterday and he said
he goes I'll see you on Thursday I was
like wait
what so no maybe I'll be honest I find
it difficult to remember appointments
I'm going to say very often I can't I'm
really not good at that and you could
you can speak the truth I was going to
say Lena now's your chance go for it
yeah what what would you have me to put
in here Lena very yeah that's what I
thought I was almost asking you faci
justly cuz I knew it was bad love it if
a task or project requires a lot of
thought I will often delay in getting it
started hm
the task or project requires a lot of
thought yeah I'll say very
often I find it difficult to sit still
and often fidget or squirm that's never
I I sit still I'll sit still all day
your feet are all over the place always
you're squirming in that chair 24/7 so
what does they mean sit sit still you're
right now fidgeting right I do that with
my legs a lot so yeah but is that what
they mean yeah yeah oh they don't mean
like oh I'm I got to leave my house and
do something they could mean that but
cuz I don't do
that I can't sit still for a long time I
have to walk around that's what I
thought it meant see I don't have to get
up and walk around or anything like
that so then let's say
sometimes often I'd say I'd say often
really you're a fidgeter yeah you're a
squirmy person you're a squirmer dude
you're squirm worm El does always yell
at me cuz I shake the whole bed with my
all right I would describe myself as
being on the go and feel compelled to do
things as if driven by a motor never
that's never that's me to do things as
if
well I'm never on the go and I never
feel compelled to do things that's one
of my big problems frankly is I have
a a crushing um disease of just being
lazy I just have a c that's been the
Obstacle of my whole life it's just
right okay persistent aggressive
laziness right find it hard to remain
focused in group
[Music]
settings you know yes did did was this
happen to you guys ever like in a in a
classroom during like long conversations
about whatever that you just get
completely lost like that happens to
everybody you're like what the are
we talking about right now like that
happens to everybody I don't think it
happens to everyone I see even Dan
giving it a little I mean I I guess it
has happened I would say not too often
for me it happened very often for
me I would always go wait so what are we
doing I would always say that in groups
or I would just get really anxious was
like oh my God if the Teacher Calls on
me I don't even know what the I
didn't even know what realm of answer
they're looking for I've had that before
on the show that's fair you're doing
other
stuff yeah you're not doing other stuff
so what are I I am there there was one
time you asked me something and I was
like uh yeah yeah yeah whatever you say
but like I thought it was like I don't
know I thought it was clear that I was
kind of lost but then people in chat
were like what the is wrong with AB
but I was kind of
just you should have agreed to that yeah
you shouldn't have yeah oops I was like
whatever you say boss I was like do you
think Michael Jackson
uh should be exhumed and uh DNA
tested yep whatever you say boss I
should have titled my video we got
pregnant at
Neverland wow that's a weird
title I just took the uh Autism test you
did uhhuh what' you get uh you
experienced many typical signs of autism
huh H how what what what send me the
screenshot cuz I I mean Zach you do you
are like I just made your
day no I'm not denying it it actually
explains a lot I think we crashed the
ADHD test website oh wait send me a
screenshot I want to see how many points
you got okay but you're in the middle of
the test if it crashed then you're not
going to get your result fin quick
you're not going get your your official
diagnosis that you will take very
seriously I'm in it's going to work I
find it hard to remain F I'll say often
I W say very often I'll say often my
mind feels very cluttered and it's hard
for me to concentrate on one thing at a
[Music]
time you know I I could I could say yes
but the thing is like it's I've never
thought about it cuz it it's never
really been a problem for
me can I give you an outsider
perspective perhaps yeah of course I
would for you I would answer very on
this one my mind feels very cluttered
and it's hard for me to concentrate on
one thing at a time based on how I flow
through the show uh not just the show I
just say in life in our group chat give
me give me what in our group chat how
you sense that sometimes
sometimes there's left left turns we're
having a conversation I sent you a video
of like someone a person on a wheelchair
falling down the elevator exactly like
that but what do you do you're not just
sitting at your phone like concentrating
on our text conversation there's I get
it I get it but just I've known you for
a long time now you say very often or
often I guess often you should answer
truthfully to you I you should answer
truthfully to yourself and of course
like anything it varies there there when
you're in like serious mode you can you
can buckle down and concentrate on
something but that's what I was going to
say in the dayto day on average
definitely leaning the other way okay I
said
sometimes I make decisions quickly and
fail to Think Through the consequences
that's very often I would say so can be
fairly
impulsive I make decisions quickly and
fail to Think Through the consequences
maybe often maybe
often I am often irritable with a short
fuse I would say
rarely yeah I mean since I'm medicated
I'm I was gonna say and in it's you used
to be a lot more irritable not really
anymore so here's the thing when I was
you can be when I was a young adult
before I started like having anxiety and
stuff I was I was never got irritable or
had a short fuse but then when I started
dealing with all the anxiety and stuff
it really I feel like me up but
now that I'm medicated again I'm I feel
like back to where I was which basically
never are
rarely so I'll say
rarely I think that's fair yeah I have
mood swings some ever is like kind of
soci like who doesn't get irritated
stoic just I have no emotion I have no
problems yeah I have mood swings
sometimes feeling quite High other times
quite
low I don't know about
that I don't think so
rarely I often miss what is being said
to me in conversations I don't think so
I don't think so rarely unless it's me
unless it's a that's good point that's
true okay come on now what so I finished
the the quiz oh loading no guys can you
everybody bail oh no
no you guys you got to bail you got to
let me load this no Ethan got the CL FL
diagnosed with cloud service
Interruption yo I have a Gateway timeout
dude that doesn't sound good at all oh
God all right Zach send me your
I did it's in Discord let me
see these results indicate that you
experienced many typical signs of autism
16 right in the middle I got a little
just halfway I got half I got half ISM
yeah what should I do
now I mean I've already I've kind of
known this
myself apparently they say yeah go all
the please remember that this test only
indicates common signs of autism based
on your experience your results is not a
clinical diagnosis however it does mean
that you do have autism yeah
y yeah um so by the way uh it is time to
speak with Sean uh he just joined the
waiting room a moment ago hold on though
I'm I'm sensing that I may yeah I'll get
to him but okay I was just going to say
I'm sensing that I might actually be
more hdhd ADHD than I ever suspected I
have never thought of myself that way
ever
ever I'd like to see my score I think
based on my score I think you'd probably
have like 30 what was your score
35 that's fairly close to you I could
give you
the5 out of 50 I think that I went to if
you actually want to get tested but for
what do you do about it well I did it
cuz I needed extra time taking tests
right say if it's not interfering with
your life then I wouldn't I don't like
the medicine for that like I tried
I've tried all and I hated it yeah I
have it I don't I just take it if I like
feel that I really need it really yeah
and I haven't used it since school I
don't think I hate it it just
made me so anxious I couldn't sleep I
didn't I didn't feel any beneficial
feelings from that drug just negative
yeah it's good for a period of time and
then it's just a nightmare for some
people not everyone sorry you must
completed test for accessing this page
you I have ADHD you think
I'm going to be able to fill that out
again hell no
no all right and also before I get to
Sean I do want to uh do what was the
poll am I going to do the heart attack
challenge or no uh it was uh it bugged
out but it was 56% yes to uh 40 whatever
no let's do it maybe I'll fall asleep
maybe I'll explode we're going to find
out here today I mean you could just do
one you haven't even one yet no two is
the one cuz both the the first dude that
died he drank two back to back he got
the free refill I'm going to have to
order two cuzz I'm not there to get the
free refill they're going to use this as
proof that they didn't die by it like a
red yeah this is a you're trying to do
them a a favor basically just slam
doning on them an expert uh witness yeah
Emily says I'm a licensed clinical
social worker autism ADHD and complex
pdsd all have overlapping symptoms so
that could be something to look
into
thanks I'm I'm I'm good you know what I
mean like I don't need any
more I'm okay for now we don't need more
diagnosises and I don't need know Jake
do a little video on me
no all right let's bring in Shawn we do
need to order Panera but I also need to
pee I don't know why I need to pee so
much today third time since I came in
here the freak what the freak but I'll
be right back and then we're going to
talk to Sean's harrowing experience
about being kidnapped
um
it's crazy it's absolutely nuts and not
funny at all right so we'll keep the
comedy we're going to tune their comedy
down that it's not funny it's not funny
I know but the way you said it makes
makes me giggle and then I seem like an
assho that's on you bro if you find it
funny we were joking about it earlier
bro if you find it funny I don't find it
funny I find it funny how you're
insisting why youing F laughing at you
not laughing at Sean I'm laughing at you
my face there's no you're dead
serious that's true and that's why it's
so funny all right let me be right back
okay imagine it imagine if Ethan Klein
got a lower
[Music]
face wow what a voice literally what a
voice what a voice we haven't even
talked about this yet but this is a
little teaser for later in the show
I guess just everyone at home just
imagine it for a second the way he whals
on that note is
[Music]
crazy
imagine I can see it
beautiful cured my
ADHD all I can think about is Ninja's
loow I Fus clearly focusing my M razor
sharp right now like the razor that cut
Ninja's fade yeah you and me we're on
the same
page uh somebody said I didn't get my
ADHD diagnosis until 35 because I was
always hung up on the hyperactive part
read more on the symptoms was
enlightening for
sure yeah
um you know you don't want to diagnose
anybody but it it does kind of does kind
of fit for Ethan doesn't it kind of
makes sense a little bit anxiety is
often misdiagnosed as ADHD fair enough
uh I'm a licensed clinical social worker
autism oh we read that one earlier uh
somebody just gave a
2B a 2B donation just said touch of the
tism that's what I
saying who are they referring
[Music]
to maybe Z cuz he sent his
results Zach you did the wait you also
did the uh the ADH D1 oh wait this is
Cam sorry no I did the tism gotcha I
mean this you're right in the middle
yeah half ISM you got the half ISM
diagnosed with half ISM uh somebody said
birds of a feather flock together right
yeah
true
uh I don't know what this means but
there's some allegations against you
Olivia oh God can Olivia please
acknowledge the allegations that she's
actually Tate mccree's secret
twin love that compliment doppelgangers
for real who's uh who is that she's like
a new pop girly and M sometimes people
say I look like her and I love it okay
see it a little bit
mhm sure thank you thank you everybody
thank you shout out Meg Shep M
[Music]
uh why didn't Ethan news report
Nashville's blizzard we got 8 in of snow
overnight and I've been stuck in my
apartment for 3 days I wish he had
warned us sad face not a sunny day in
Nashville yeah that is kind of lowy a
stormy day in
Nashville sorry about that I
responsibility I'm hearing Panera
doesn't deliver here why are they
with me o constantly
consistently this
is how far is it Lena could you maybe go
I'm sick of them blue balling me like
I'm just I have to put my foot down let
me check I think the nearest one is
really far and that's why last time we
ordered it took like forever oh okay so
then that doesn't sound like a fun
project okay there's a gentleman waiting
to speak to us we're going to have to
set paner aside go ahead for the next
few minutes so here we go I'm bringing
in
Sean yeah big
welcome
rectang and reang Mr rectangular himself
Ladi and gentlemen welcome to the show
Sean
Stevens hi guys can you hear me hey Sean
what's that behind you there you got
your like your
resume oh yeah I've got my standard
everyday Zoom aesthetic as CEO baby I
change
chill back and see my house ah beautiful
beautiful so um thanks for calling in
nice to see you how you been I mean
other than the
kidnapping yeah a little light
kidnapping in the morning uh I've been
good I've been back 10 days has been
since the uh event so I'm feeling good
again I finally got rid of the the feel
and look like I just got kidnapped
aesthetic yeah and starting to feel like
I'm back to being myself which is nice
have you considered that if you would
have come to our live show that perhaps
the kidnapping would never have taken
place I did not consider that until this
very moment yeah something to think
about converging path but anyway no Ser
I'm glad that everything is okay I was
actually quite I was worried as hell
when I saw that headline it was it was
uh really quite
unreal yeah listen it was a crazy crazy
circumstance you know I was thinking
about it as sitting here uh watching
this great podcast on ADHD and going pee
and things and uh and and the uh the the
thought cross me that actually I still
am the luckiest man alive because
there's other people that have had
traumatic events that they just keep
going like they go for weeks or months
or years and I had like a traum
traumatic event and admittedly it was
the lowest point of my life but uh wow
uh I gotta say the fact is it's over I'm
home I'm safe my kids
yeah so yeah
um so you went to mount kilamanjaro
everything was good there you guys hiked
you did you you you did the I traveled
how many miles did you travel what was
the official one there I think it was
12,352 although I could be wrong
somebody could correct me on that right
and I did a video for you guys at the
top which is you know took a lot of
energy I got to tell you it was very
high it was very high yes we we enjoyed
it we all enjoyed it we watched it
everybody was stoked to see you hear
from you yeah so after uh you you uh
traversed the mountain you guys decided
to go visit your mom in South Africa
right correct yes so she's been there
since I was a kid she runs an orphan
project orphan isn't really the word
it's it's more like vulnerable children
is the is how we describe it now and in
that part of Africa there's a lot of
kids who need a lot of help one out of
every five children is is in a bad way
and she runs a huge project where she
brings in literally hundreds of kids at
a time and sort of figures out who are
the children with uh with food haven't
eaten who are the kids who need clothes
who are the kids who uh need advocacy
just need some papers or some help
they've lost their mother and father and
so and sort of a big project to help a
lot of people all at the same time and
she's been doing it since I was a kid I
mean I have not been back in 20 years my
first time returning this year in
decades and so you V so what city is she
in uh it used to be called Nel sprit
that's what most people know it as but
it's now called bombella bombella and so
tell I guess walk me through how this is
how this happened you you arrived in uh
what's where did you arrive when you
traveled there by car do you mind kind
of going through it if that if you're
okay with that yeah not all you know the
it's a pretty traumatic story so if
everybody's okay with that if you need
to shut me down like let me know I'm
I'll talk about it happily but want to
make sure I don't stress anybody out
that's a that's a good uh disclaimer to
make for sure but I think we're okay but
it's nice to make that disclaimer but
yeah I want I want to hear from you
sounds good yeah so we went to uh
there's another country which is inside
South Africa called used to be called
Swaziland now it's called the kingdom of
eswatini uh and in the Kingdom of
eswatini there's a there's a children's
home uh where they have I think 884 kids
there uh and so we went to that home
because they needed medicine that they
couldn't get in eswatini so we brought
them the medicine from South Africa uh
and that meant that we left a little bit
later in the day than you'd usually
leave so we got there sort of midday and
we hung out with the kids for a while
and then we went home back to where her
uh her project is which is near bombella
uh and so on the way home we we'd gotten
there gotten back late so we were in
downtown like the downtown core of the
city of previously known as Nels sprit
uh and we stopped at the gas station and
we uh we were we had one person with us
we let off and on the way out of the
city uh a cop pulled up behind me so I
and I I looked up up the window and you
know the blue lights and flashing and so
uh you know I did the appropriate thing
you do and a police officer approaches
the a vehicle like that you know he pull
side and I'm thinking you know I'm
driving on the wrong side of the street
I've probably done something wrong you
know I've always got that sort of guilt
you like guilt you feel when somebody
when a police officer pulls you over and
uh so I pull over to the side and uh
roll down the window and an officer
comes to the front window and he says
you know you I need to see your license
in registration and so I'm immediately
in that mode where where's my license
looking for it and I pull it out I look
at the police officer and I'm like well
you're wearing a police vest but you're
you don't have a police hat on and you
don't have a police shirt on I said look
are you a police officer I mean can I
see your police designation and and then
he started to get really you know riled
up and demanded and tell me that you
know what I was and you s start yelling
at me and I'm like this is really
strange Behavior coming from a police
officer uh and then finally you know as
we were sitting there getting in this
little fight uh he verbally he says turn
off your car so say okay I'll turn off
my car you go get me your police officer
badge and we'll be good and so I turn
off my car and as soon as that happens
he reaches into the car and he unlocks
my door and now I'm thinking okay he's
trying to drag me out of the car and uh
do something and and instead I I sort of
grab the door I'm pulling it shut and
we're sort of scuffling uh and and then
I realized you know something's really
off here and I decided I'm to try and
get the car but put back into gear and
then all of a sudden all the doors open
I've got my two kids in the back seat
and my mother sitting beside me in the
passenger seat and guys with guns jump
into the car nice uh and point guns at
myself at my
kids uh so yeah not a pleasant
experience definitely unpleasant and now
so can I keep going is that okay let me
ask let me ask some uh yeah no I mean of
course so when you when you're pulled
over what kind of Road are you on like
what's the atmosphere there are you in a
city are you in like rural area what's
it like no we're in a city like right
across from the Magistrate's Office like
like know it's at night so it's dark and
the streetlights you know are sort of
half there okay but know there's lots of
traffic there's cars whipping by us like
this is in the middle of town kind of so
as they're holding you guys up with
weapons there's There Is people driving
by consistently yeah both directions
like just as if that probably put your
your guard down a little bit getting
pulled over like in a city like that for
sure absolutely wow yeah so they so now
uh obviously I'm like okay I've got a
gun pointed at my head I'm not GNA fight
anymore start shuffling so he the guy
pulls me out of the car and then tries
to force me into the back seat with my
kids and the back seat is is is actually
folded down so I can't really get in
and so the guy starts hitting me in the
head with a gun you know to either knock
me unconscious or get me to move or
whatever it was and I'm like guys stop
hitting me I'm just I'm trying to we
need to move the seats so I can get in
so I get in the back and obviously
family is distraught
obviously uh not a pleasant situation at
all uh so I'm sitting in the back and
now we've got these gangsters I know
what they call as salant sitting in the
back seat with me and they say put your
heads down and they jump in and they
drive off uh like unsafely at the speed
of light and they say keep your heads
down keep your heads down and I'm like
okay we're getting we went from a car
sort of hijacking stealing wallets to to
now some sort of kidnapping experience
anyway so they're holding us down uh
against the sort of front of the car and
and now they're threatening us they're
threatening to kill us they're
threatening us with they're they're
hitting me in the head with a flashlight
they're you know as I'm trying to sort
of protect my kids and I'm you know
imagine all things going through my head
it's not a pleasant set of thoughts
going through my head yeah
absolutely so anyway they they we drive
for about half an hour out into a rural
area in the middle of nowhere and they
pull up to the side of a uh basically
the like a little sort of a forested
section and there's a cliff and
literally then we get out of they open
all the doors to the car and they start
grabbing our wallets and demanding and
yelling at us and threatening us and and
basically threatening to kill us thrw us
over the cliff uh and then finally the
guy says Okay I want to see your cards
your your your ATM cards and your credit
cards and I'm like fine you know it's
just money I don't care like take it
like it's all yours and so I give him
the ATM card and he sort of puts the the
code he ask what the code is and say
Here's the code like take all the money
I don't care he had like a card scanner
with him and so he went back to a truck
so there was a truck that was following
us a pickup truck yeah the Dual with a
small back and uh and he was testing the
card on some sort of device in the back
then he came back to the car and he said
look if this is wrong I'm going to kill
you and rape your daughter
Jesus so and then there's some other
stuff that happened like he held my hand
held a gun against my hand and said if
this is you know you if you do anything
I'm gonna blow your hand off you know
sort of all sorts of stuff like that and
he's my mother who just had surgery
there this you know the guy is a sitting
on her and you know not violating her
but pushing her around Etc there's some
other stuff I won't talk about but just
just unpleasant a behavior in general
how old is your daughter she turned 18
on kjaro two
weeks so they grab me drag me out of the
car throw me on the ground and now
they're kicking me in the face I did I
just didn't make any public appearances
last week because I was bleeding out of
the eyeballs which is not pleasant but
fortunately no
scars externally anyway anyway they
throw me on the ground and a guy's
pointing a gun at me where the other guy
kicks me and he's demanding money
demanding other stuff and finally
they're not happy in some reason about
what they got so they grab grab me and
they take me back and I'm like obviously
this whole time I'm thinking what's
going on with my kids is my mom okay and
obviously you know I'm the biggest guy
around so they're picking on me the most
thank God they grab me and they drag me
back to the back of their pickup truck
and they throw me in the back of the
pickup truck and they grab my kids and
they throw them in the back of the
pickup truck and we also had another
child with was a 12-year-old they threw
her in the back of the pickup truck and
they and then I didn't know where my
mother was this whole time and then they
they put myself my kids and they closed
the back of the pickup truck so we're
encased in this little dark space in the
back of this pickup truck and they're
yelling at us that they're going to kill
us and that you know we got to be quiet
and then for hours turned out to be
about three and a half hours they drove
around and what they did is basically
they went to ATM to ATM pulling money
out of cards and they were G us if it
was the wrong card or something they
would you know pull us out do whatever
and then they said okay we've gotten all
the money we can we're going to take you
back to your car and I'm thinking okay
well is that real like this whole time
I'm thinking I'm dead like I've seen
their faces I've seen the license plate
I've seen the make of the car like I
kind of know where I am and so now you
know this is a highly unpleasant
situation and they take us back and for
about an hour we're now driving back
hypothetically to our car but my son
says look we're not going back to our
car dad like this is this is obviously
farther than we went and so now I'm
having this existential crisis about
we're not going to make it and I'm like
son like we got to take these guys out
or do something about it like I don't
know karate or anything like we we just
you know we got to do something so I
said to the girls I'm like you guys need
to run when the thing opens and will
take on the attackers how old is your
son
15 so we're got this like plan happening
and we're like trying to S going okay
and I'm certain as soon as I get out of
the the car I'm taking a bullet to the
head which is not pleasant idea anyway
so we get out of the car they're
pointing guns at us and our car is
actually there and they're like Okay
jump in the in the car and you guys can
go and I'm like okay what really are
they G to shoot us on the way out what's
going to happen here uh and eventually
we got back in the car I literally said
goodbye to the kidnapping slash bad guys
and we drove off holy just like
that wow yeah so it was a it was an
amazing holiday punctuated by a
perfectly horrible experience at the end
I highly recommend not doing that if any
of on Holiday by way when you guys you
guys got back in so what happened they
drove your car somewhere else and then
yeah that's what we think drove our car
somewhere else to sort of H you know
we've actually got you know we'll know
where the car went the police have all
this information we're still tracking
our phones like I know exactly where our
phones are are which is bizarre you know
you know they they haven't can still use
find my iPhone and go see where they are
they're
probably you made a good point like you
you knew who they were you had all the
details that that didn't deter them it's
probably I would imagine some level of
corruption going on there with the
police no or or do you not suspect that
the police actually admitted that there
was corruption happening like they told
us flat out we were we were actually
there near where you got kidnapped we
got taken elsewhere as a result of
corruption inside the police uh nice wow
so yeah so when you guys got back in the
car everyone got in you did you just
drive off real quick like what was the
what was the temperature in the car I
mean obviously there must have been a a
lot of relief to get back in there with
everyone but I'm curious what was the
feeling and the conversation
thereafter yeah so immediately the
everyone started asking if we're okay
but I got to tell you I still thought we
were in danger I presumed that you know
they could still follow us back they
knew they had our phone so they now know
where we're going they that map like the
Google Map that I had running so I'm
still thinking they're going to follow
us and try and get more out of us or do
more stuff we need to get out of this
situation now yeah so I just left there
was stuff on the ground we just left the
stuff jumped in the car and immediately
drove up uh and as soon as we found
people which is about 20 minutes later
we asked them where we were and they
said you're going the wrong way and here
here's the next part so we actually
drove back and the first city we hit or
town was called White River we stopped
at the White River Police Station and
we're were like hey we just got
kidnapped this is a horrible situation
and they literally just looked at us
they were like you know there's nothing
we can do your Canadians like uh sorry
like what you're supposed to be the
police I've heard that in South Africa
specifically the crime is really crazy
like I've heard people saying that
people there's certain neighborhoods you
don't stop at the red lights because
it's just so
dangerous yeah well I don't plan to go
back to uh South Africa anytime soon I
got at this point through the macro
attitude is I don't want to go back to
Africa maybe I'm not going to let my
children out of their RS I'm just going
to wrap them in pillows
right tape and
yeah but now I'm calming down a little
bit I'm like okay we can go travel
elsewhere just let's lay off Africa for
a while so you guys drove off about you
said about 20 minutes to the nearest
police station and they didn't they
didn't care yeah and I literally I I was
like guys back in the car we're going to
another so put everybody back in the car
and we drove to the bigger city we
actually drove back to two blocks where
the guys from where the guys picked us
up uh that's where the big local police
station was and once we got there to be
honest they they were a little bit
confused literally they said hey well we
really can't help you you know you're
Canadians I'm not sure what we're going
to do and as it happened there was a a
member of the tourism board there and
the tourism person freaked out on them
and was like guys we got to do something
for these people and I got to say she
was a rock star and she sort of helped
us all the way through the thing and
suddenly we're in contact with the
embassy and then we had you know the
sort of squat team showed up and you
know turned thing and suddenly it's 7
o'clock in the morning we're sitting at
home with guys machine guns everywhere
and literally I packed my bags took my
kids put them on a plane and ran away
like I'm done yeah
yeah oh man that is harrowing that is a
horrible experience but thankfully I
mean I'm so I'm so happy for you that
everyone is safe guys it's so nice to
see you guys I can't tell that was it is
and honestly thank you for having me on
here you know uh somebody said to me
when you go through a really traumatic
experience if you if you hold it in and
you keep it to yourself then you have to
carry it with you for the rest of your
life but if you share it with people
that you love
uh then they can carry a little tiny bit
for you so I love you guys and love your
family I appreciate it damn thank you so
much thanks the the the feeling is
mutual oh yeah so you guys uh you guys
flew home like the same day the the
night after came home and uh got a play
how are the kids
doing ah amazing my children are like I
think I hard boiled them at some point I
gotta say I I I have these moments where
I realize I'm a terrible father because
you know you shouldn't have put your
kids through this like it's not
something that you should never have put
your kids in a situation I wouldn't
blame yourself for that one yeah I mean
I yeah you know life either grinds you
down or polishes you up just depends on
what you decide you're made of so I
think that they've just been amazing
like I can't stop crying they're fine so
maybe get them
later wow so yeah I'm curious how did
they know how did they spot you guys do
you think they probably identified you
guys as tourists right ahead of the
time yeah they actually admitted that so
they said that they knew us I'm not sure
like maybe this is psychological stuff
but they we had previously stopped at a
McDonald's oddly enough uh and they said
that they saw us at the McDonald's and
they followed us uh my hair was not
green at that point uh you know it had
sort of washed out to uh kill Manjaro
white uh so I I I don't they recognized
me I think they just recognized us as
rich people and we were driving a rental
car like I you know it wasn't a nice
rental car it was just a normal ass
rental car so you know now I would also
say that they had hijacked or tried to
hijack somebody the night before and
they hijack somebody two days later and
you know it's it's an ongoing issue for
that region so the police really don't
care about it at all these guys are
doing this like just dayto day
apparently uh yeah this is great for the
tourism there I agree the I'm sure
everybody's racing to to visit beautiful
South Africa I feel I feel bad for them
for that this cannot be good for their
entire industry you know for for a very
poor place you know to scare off
everybody that might come and spend
money there look there are not enough
zebras or giraffes in the entire world
that make me want to go back to that
place yeah yeah yeah well yeah it's the
S of a great trauma for you guys yeah
um so they my question is uh so you dyed
your hair since coming back how long
since when you landed did you go back
green uh Sunday you know what my uh
there there's like trauma counselors
who' been in front of all these trauma
counselors and they're really helpful
and everything but I got to tell you
there's nothing better than going and
seeing your hair stylist the
barber yeah that is the
way uh so I I love my hair stylist and
she looked after me very well and
honestly like shaving off all of the
like noise of all of that was like the
moment that I'm like okay now I'm back I
can continue to go back to doing loving
things like helping businesses and
making music and dancing and stuff like
stuff that it's positive for the
world wow well that's an experience I
hope that nobody ever goes through that
is really really tough I agree I agree H
how much money did they steal from you
in the end like uh through all the trips
to ATMs and stuff uh we lost about
$20,000 in the end about 10 in cash and
10 in
stuff okay truth is I don't care you
know I I had every insurance I thought
that you could get but every insurance
company's like oh no you didn't have
this and you're in a card so car
insurance doesn't cover it because this
is supposed to cover I spent about a day
calling insurance companies and now I'm
like okay I can go make $20,000 fast
than I can talk to you insurance
companies you suck yeah oh that's great
that's a nice co son for the insurance
uh out there for the insurance world
they're like excuse me you didn't have
terrorism insurance so literally that's
one of the things they said they like
one this is an act of God I'm like this
is definitely not an act an act of a
human being
literally that is the very intentional
Act of a human being yeah so you work
are
you you inspired here are we circular
are we rectangular has it changed your
shape at
all yeah comments have said you know are
are you going to now go all dark and
start writing like dark music I I don't
know but you know to date most of my
music is about bad relationships and so
it's already depressing enough I should
be about how happy and amazing I am so
I'm not an amazing artist that sits down
and creatively knows exactly what
they're going to write like a Taylor
Swift I'm more like collecting toenails
you know I just have like a jar of
emotions and I put stuff in at the end
I'm like hey look at this crazy jar I
have of music and so it's probably going
to come out in some horrible way later
I'm sorry for that in advance oh yes we
accept your apology but we'll be
watching regardless yay y brother well
that's well I mean honestly at the end
of the day I'm just relieved you guys
are all okay you know that that that was
a I know it's weird to say but it's it's
a happy ending in the sense that you
guys gotten they brought you back to
your car and you guys left I mean that's
that's amazing it is right like when you
get your kids back at the end
you know my my uh advice for travelers
is always never take anything you can't
afford to lose with you traveling uh
including your life so if you're
traveling and you're afraid you're going
to lose your wallet or your keys or your
special sweater don't take your sweater
with you but it's a whole other thing
when you take your kids traveling
because you can't afford to lose your
kids and so you know for me it's this
huge thing do I take my kids traveling
ever again or do I keep them in their
rooms like I I have to like do some
counseling around that for the rest of
my life probably well well they're
they're close to being adults now but
yeah I I see where you're you you you're
feeling a tremendous amount of guilt for
what happened to the kids yeah you know
what definitively they're both adults
now like any shred of children that they
have is gone now I'm sorry to say that's
maybe the guilt that I have like how do
you have innocence left after you've you
know been thrown in the back of a truck
and kidnapped that's uh
unpleasant yeah yeah know I don't a
great dad in this situation I feel like
a terrible fu well did you did you go
there knowing that
like it's extremely dangerous I wouldn't
expect to get kidnapped anywhere for
Christ say visiting your
mom yeah I mean she's been there 35
years and never had that problem yeah
exactly I you know what I drive down the
street every day and lots of people have
car accidents and I'm not expecting to
have a car accident right but you know
if you drive incredibly unsafely you're
more likely to have a car accident and
if you travel to the depths of Africa
you're more likely to get get kidnapped
I I think those are so the increase of
likelihood like I as a person I absorb a
lot of risk and you know sometimes when
you push the boundaries the boundaries
push back it just sucks when it
happens well I'm glad you guys are all
okay I hope you're not too hard on
yourself there but and I hope you guys
are all getting like you guys are all
doing like therapy and stuff after that
oh for sure from hairdress to
professional all the way through and you
know coming and talking to you yes the
best the most therapeutic people have
said
yeah whether you're therapist that it's
a good story I mean I'll say for the
kids like if I had a kidnapping story if
I was in college that'd be kind of dope
that'd be sick like true like I was
kidnapped like what that's crazy that's
a good story I will have a story for a
long time the one thing is you want to
sort of balance having a good story and
not it being The Narrative of your life
like being a victim who got kidnapped
like that sucks like I don't to be
honest like I don't want to be known as
the guy who got kidnapped that sucks as
a narrative you're the rectangular guy
yeah rectangular guy let's go back to
I'll say it's you're so close to the
incident it feels like that but I
promise you that that won't be the case
not not at all yeah you're not gonna be
the kidnapped guy promise the kid guy
yeah now so totally people going are
going to come up to me on the street and
be like hey you're the kidnapped guy no
no no don't do that hey I was an Oliver
tree concert on Monday night which is
like our first as a family first outing
and uh I got you know accosted by
everybody who was like you're the H3 guy
which is that's good it wasn't the
kidnapping thing no it wasn't the
kidnapping guy did anyone know you were
kidnapped yeah you know a bunch of
people did most people knew me as
rectangular like we're seeing
rectangular Lind and things like that so
thank you for that I really appreciate
it yeah I think if you're hearing it
people it's just because people care but
I I don't think think in a year people
are going to still be saying kidnap guy
especially with all the tremendous music
and all the shapes we look forward to
celebrating right yes exactly I am going
to do my best to do beautiful amazing
things for the rest of my life and be
known for that instead for sure yes yes
although I might have to write some
really terrible low effort book at some
point you know just no I won't I promise
that well there I'm there for whatever
man I don't want to write a book about
this I want to be over and move on life
yeah well well I'm glad you guys are
okay that's a hell of a that's a hell of
a story thank you so yeah is there any
advice you give people traveling there
is there anything you wish you did
differently that might help other people
or did you feel it just kind
of came on you so
fast yeah it just came on real fast you
know when you travel stuff bad stuff
does happen I mean it traveled all over
the world not just in the last year but
for all of my life and everyone in a
while if you talk to somebody who's been
to 50 countries they will tell you
they've been mugged or held up or you
know it's unfortunately part of the
traveling world and if you don't but you
also get to see beautiful things and
taste beautiful things and meet
beautiful people and there's all sorts
of positives that come with it so you
know I might need to take a break for a
little bit I'm G to visit safe places
like I don't know Ukraine uh no I'm
sorry there you
go
I'm thinking I'm thinking
Sweden oh yeah there you go you're G to
get you're going to get mugged and
kidnapped or something absolutely
absolutely I guarantee don't jinx it but
I yeah Sweden is very safe right yeah no
kidnappings no I don't think so very
little very little kidnapp low level of
kidnapping Iceland Iceland doesn't even
have mosquitoes like that's a place
Iceland you'll be good cuz everybody
knows everyone there if you just you
know they they'll be like oh there goes
Kevin he's kidnapping again there is
volcano just kind of perpetually
erupting true natural disasters have you
considered that you know form of a
terrible place to go yeah that's a
natural disaster waiting to happen
where's the safest place for you to go I
wonder Disneyland Disneyland people have
died at Disney but overall it's probably
safe you know oh apparently even with
even
with the volcanoes Iceland is the safest
place on Earth really that according to
Google so the safest and by what metric
do they measure that
uh let's see uh it looks like it's
actually some like un organization that
sounds good Sean say yeah that's okay I
think Iceland must be the next place I
travel got back on the horse at some
point right uh so you know or I should
also come to LA but is La safe I don't
know are you do you guys
moderately there there kidnappings are
it's a big city they happen probably
every now and then no I'm kidding I
think it's a I think it's a safe City I
mean obviously there's certain
neighborhoods that you won't go
to like you have to intentionally go
there true they're going to be unsafe
but um anywhere that you would be
traveling in La I'm sure would is I I
feel safe here personally yeah I like LA
right on well that I'll put that on my
list as well Iceland and La those there
you go not as safe as Iceland though I
can't make that guarantee
that's good yeah I I reorganize all the
places I want to go in my bucket list to
the degree of safety now instead ofree
of fun skydiving is definitely off the
list well Sean I'm glad everyone's okay
and I appreciate you calling in and
sharing your story with
us love you guys Len it's so nice to see
your faces and still be alive look
forward to we got to get you a live
performance going here soon that'll be
super fun I would love to do that yes
yeah we'll make that we we'll figure
that out but um there it is Sean Stevens
Sean Stevens all right love you all stay
rectangular my friend stay rectangular
exactly thank you thank you thank you
see you later take care
bye as I said not
funny it's not funny it's pretty
traumatic yeah uh that's like a I mean
that's like a Bonafide nightmare yeah my
God I'm so happy they're okay they could
have so easily not been yeah that's
really got to be like the greatest
relief of your life when they're just
like okay here's your
car I mean I
guess I'm just speculating here but they
were probably wise enough to realize
that killing foreign Nationals yeah
would get get them in a lot more trouble
than it's worth you know that would have
been news their kidnapping was yeah I
mean and that I mean that often times H
like if like a an American citizen say
is traveling overseas and gets up
murdered the American government will
lean on that country to make sure it
gets properly investigated and
everything whereas you
know them being Canadian they probably
realize H it's it's probably just a lot
easier to just send them on their way
well and especially if the police don't
do anything anyway I'm
guaranteed that there's police Chiefs
and police sergeants or whatever getting
rubbed down 20,000 if they're doing that
that's crazy numbers man if they're
doing that on a daily basis that's very
true that's horrible I'm scared now
yeah it made me so sad to hear him say
that he feels like a bad dad he sounds
like yeah he's that story makes him
sound like a wonderful dad who cares so
much about his kids that's tough cuz
it's like the trauma makes you think
up things I kind of empathize
with him in the sense that like I but
it's it's not his fault it's just
horrible that he's going to feel that
way you know he called Ethan Z somebody
said I didn't notice he called me Zach
apparently are you the one talking to
him Zach no Olivia is so Zach okay wait
he called you Zach that's what people
are saying in chat I think no you called
him I called him Z yeah why did I call
him no I mean I didn't hear that call
him maybe you must have misheard me
maybe but I call him Zach you got to
pull it back yeah you got to pull the
tap pull the tape pull it up somebody
you got to pull
it h well me
[Music]
man now let's get back to Our Roots
imagine so what happened with Panera
it's a 30- minute drive we ordered
though Le's order oh we did order it's
going to be a while but we ordered it's
it's been ordered yeah is there an
EA I'm so excited it says it's going to
be ready for pickup um at 3:40 so for
the driver to pick it up yeah and it's
not going to be ready for pickup for an
hour mhm they're like really busy
apparently hold the phone there's no way
I'm going to get that food before yeah
that's that's a how it was last time too
that's a rip GG if they they're picking
it up at 340 and it's 30 minutes
away ain't no way it's not going to get
here till 4:40 five can you cancel it
still let me see if not then we just got
to let it fly but if we can cancel I
guess we can just make our own Super
supercharge someone just get me lemonade
and some caffeine powder and let's get
weird with it it makes like a 5 Hour
Energy yeah
dude I do 50 hour
energy
mhm never sleep
again um okay we got the we have the um
the time stamp here did I call Sean Zack
the question is on everybody's mind
let's take a look
here roll it R thank you angular my
friend St rectangular exactly thank you
thank you thank you wait what hold on
angular my friend say rectangular
exactly maybe it said exactly you
envision me as a rectangular being
exactly exactly thank you why would I
say Z thank you well maybe you wanted
him to play the rectangular sound my
friend well I would have remember that
that if I was giving Zach a
Direction They rectangular EXA thank you
thank you thank you friend okay all
right he's Zach there's a little Zach in
all of us you know yeah dude we all
Zach yeah I'm curious if he saw the
performance of the the song I want to
know how oh
did we send it to him we should
send it to him make sure he sees it
yeah Zach shredded that live
I oh what a horrible
experience that's why I don't really go
to Mexico anymore I've talked about this
but I love Mexico as a as a country it's
so beautiful the food the people
everything about it is just amazing the
weather I love everything about it but
the cartel there is nuts it just there's
so much gang violence and and
kidnappings you know even the police are
like gang members when I
shakedowns sucks it's so close it's such
a great place yep yeah I don't
know Mexico is so much fun man so much
fun all right all
right I guess I'll explain
[Music]
that so this guy Eric DOA was doing
freestyles on Twitch and apparently this
Banger just was imagined in his mind
merged it's like Tupac says just dead
homies speaking through
me
they like asking
me why the you
make is it this is an hour long I'm
assuming it sounds like the song it is
there time stamp let me uh so I have a
feeling that he we don't get to that
juicy that big drop uh link to the clip
uh number three in the doc if you want
uh just that part I think that's what I
clicked let me try
again okay imagine Ninja got a l t
[Music]
f imagine if ninja got a low F I don't
even know what that is uh low
taper you're about to find out you do
maybe you just don't realize it's called
that yeah I just I don't know okay so
it's a pretty standard that's a popular
look these days yeah I usually get a low
taper fade you got a is it a low tapered
fade yeah I usually yeah that's what I
usually is there high taper fades is
there different yeah so what's a let me
look what's a high taperd fade just out
of curiosity
T that's clean that's a clean fade right
there that's a MC broom that boy got
lined up
good so that's a hi taper fade where it
goes really high up on your Dome the
double hairline mhm I find the fade so
funny cuz like I feel like it shouldn't
work too they cut it so high up like
there's no hair
mhm the man has no hair next to his ears
like I have hair here I've learned so
much about hair in the last uh few
months because shant tall she's a a
fully licensed Barber now oh um so I've
learned all these different type of
haircuts and hair tricks so it's
interesting how there's different names
for them does she do fades yeah yeah
High tapered and low tapered High
tapered low tapered mid tapered you know
they accidentally last time I got my
haircut they accidentally gave me a fade
and I wanted to leave this much on the
side and I
was I was so upset it was it two days
before the live show I was like I'm
going to look clean for the live show
and they me up and I got so like
down in the barber shop when I was like
bro you cut everything off and he was
like I'm not gonna make you're not
paying for this I was like I'll pay but
but I feel like he didn't let me pay he
bailed cuz I got so upset I wasn't mean
or anything I was just visibly very
upset you were sad about it he probably
looked fresh though right no he did he
came in not feeling himself but I told
him he looked really good I like I
thought it looked good no it looked
goofy as I don't think proportions
are all up now he was texting the
group chat through the whole thing he
was like you guys something horrible
happened up I think I sent a
picture of it I think the fade actually
is a nice cut it just if to me it's so
high it feels like would be silly but it
it it is a nice it's a nice
Cut well I like it because I could just
be messy on top if the sides are faded
cuz it looks like you're not just you
didn't just let yourself go ah you're
clean I should try doing a fade once
that'd be fire right you imagine if
Ethan got a low tape for fade he got one
wait when did I get a we did a segment
with the fire uh the fire haircut
outside I got a fade on that yeah H3
fire let's see H3 fire haircut
imagine if Ethan got
a what is this wait why is this a
picture of
Moses wonder if he got the fire haircut
the this is the weirdest post ever
they'd be number one probably after we
did that segment right after let's see
um here here's the Highlight I
think coming up Ian's beard
Ian's been getting a lot of comments on
his beard so we're going to have a whole
segment about Ian so let's see the final
product here let me see that fade
immensely painful right I mean he's got
a flame on his head for like oh this is
just okay I'm out this isn't the sketch
I'm looking for
it you can send me a screenshot that'd
be easier but the thing is um so this
Meme got has a lot of legs to the point
where uh Ninja actually did get the low
tapered F we got we got an answer to the
question you don't have to imagine it
anymore here is uh a
covers imagine if ninja got
a imagine if ninja got a
[Music]
f I bet he see more
moving be like stacking over stacking B
joke would have
to be guilty considering the
fact that he would we was playing
fortnite
with damn dude it's it's a beautiful
song makes me feel something like
there's really something about this slow
tapered fade hello
hello there's another
one this is fortnite is so bizarre
you have Family Guy Jack Family Guy
this all makes so much sense to me and
song he starts doing like uh Super
Saiyan yeah Jack Family Guy only in
fortnite I imagine we got our first
nominee for next year's steamies for
song of the Year song of the year baby
low tapered fade it's much appreciated
out in the
world what is this hello
aado oh this is just a copyrighted song
mhm 7 million views okay I'm not going
to watch it though uh Brooklyn Nets join
the
[Music]
fun so okay
interesting so ninja
responded to the phenomenon let's pull
that up he says he might get it but
here's the video he posts
he gets the legendary fade I gotta say
I'm disappointed with this video I he
could have done a a much better reveal I
felt like this was really thrown
together really it was such an epic
moment like look how he films it you
know like that's
it like he could have done something way
more epic like had some sort of hat on
and closeup that comes out yeah I mean
this is like what is this closeup on the
fade itself and then tracking shot up up
up reveal exactly it's n and it's not
funny it's not too late ninja you can
still do
[Music]
better also I don't like how he's so
happy he's feeling himself dude hold on
keep that playing I I I I think he
should be serious in this video I don't
like he's really feeling
[Music]
himself IM ninja got a yeah be serious
this matters to people you know what I
mean he he flopped it yeah but anyway we
we um we got the answer what what would
happen if ninja got a low tapered fade
and the answer we got is that nothing H
nothing happened well that's quite true
nothing
happened we got an answer fellas
[Music]
excuse official NFL Tik Tok posted a
video could you imagine if I got a low
tap
why did they post this wait why the
do they post this is this an
ad hold on what is this over could you
imagine if I got a
lower fade my God this is I feel like
this is an ad
no this is a collaboration yeah yeah no
this is an official NFL account so
somebody at the marketing team of NFL by
the way got 2 million likes so
Something's Happened that makes no sense
well he's a he's a huge Detroit Lions
fan so I
think yeah you know a lot about
Ninja Lions they won their first
something since 1993 yeah they're
kicking ass right now where is that
video I want to know how many views it
got but um it seems to me that someone
in marketing was like we got to get that
low tapered fade out on the field gave
him some tickets could you
imagine Ninja has the best life like he
was just good at a video game for like
one year and then he got he made like
$50 million and people still talk about
him like he's relevant and now he has a
braless wife giving him sandwiches it
doesn't get better he is relevant he's
he's he's the comeback he's the most
relevant he's been in years you don't
know what you're talking about maybe
he's back you know what you're talking
about nin just so back I got
multi-millions in the bank account right
I got more money than your entire
family tree has had in the last
probably a thousand years combined what
happened did did down to earth see the
CP of him flossing recently the recent
floss video I I I saw him flossing again
but you don't care not really you don't
care well now that you you mention it we
can we can reveal it I a smoke and a hot
wife you know what I'm saying maybe
it'll help I don't know I thought this
clip was pretty powerful what if I had a
braw this wife that brought me
sandwich when we went home my cousin and
his wife were wearing ninja merch
unironically and I love they watch the
show so I'm just I'm not going to talk
well I loved Ninja too for a second
then he betrayed me I forget what he did
or said but I remember he betrayed me he
did betray you yeah what did he do that
piss try to sued Pok he was goofing on
you for getting banned on Twitter oh
yeah for no reason yeah the Elon mus
like bro was free speech we could
have been friends and you went
and simped for Elon mus he has plenty of
friends as you're about to see in this
clip he has so he has too many friends
that's from him making fun of me I I
thought comedy was alive and
well I did not say that okay by the way
uh said something kind of like that
maybe in
jazz Ethan looks like he's 10 years
younger with this haircut oh this is the
fade oh people like it see the dudes I
saw their hairline is like way up here
wait wait wait say that's not really a
hold on this is Ethan's hair we're
talking about so that was probably after
a week's worth of grow right I mean
maybe that's Ethan fade yeah okay but I
find the sketch this isn't a high taper
fade you know what I'm saying it was
it's like mid taper I'd say that's a low
ass taper
fade but again I'm going to need to see
the sketch because that's a super low
one uh I'd say I don't see anything
faded there's no fade there is fade see
how it's on the bottom it's less dense I
think it's just because of the angles I
think it's a grown out fade no I
remember I remember I remember Ethan
looking at me mid getting his haircut
he's like ab's loving this right now
okay I'll get a high tapered or no not
high I'll get a low
tapered my next haircut will be a low
tapered fade hell yeah people love this
haircut huh they says Ethan looks 10
years younger so now with losing weight
and if I get a haircut then apparently
I'm going to look 20 yes sir and the
tattoo how it works it's all C and the
tattoo wow W wearing flannel youthful
you're so I am so youthful right now I'm
feeling it I've tried to learn boys over
there I've tried to learn for years how
to give myself a taper and I always
it up it's it it got so bad that I just
gave cam my my brand new razor I bought
one brand new one to try it out and I
was like you know what I'm just going to
I up my hair and I gave it to cam
it doesn't seem something easily done to
yourself the fade you know what I mean
yeah goo goo
goo all right we got so much stuff to
get to let's see you just avoiding this
video avoiding
what I'll open it I'm not avoiding the
floss I'll I'll look at the floss no
no bro hey we're New Yorkers in the rain
we got tons of friends the first uh
public flossing event since his
disastrous New York it's the night cap
ninja year review dude another New Year
flossing event what is this this was his
end of the year New Year's Eve uh stream
but is this sponsored is it just this
him who are all these people sponsored
by gamees square judging by the uh what
I don't get how many people watch this
85,000 85,000 people watch well this is
just a clip find me the I want to know
how many people watch this event okay
let's find out and then I want to
complain about why nobody me to I bet it
was a big event it was a million a
million you find it yep okay I get a
million every episode basically pretty
much pretty much if you round
up I feel like after a month or two
maybe after the break all all has passed
aill okay that was actually cool I
noticed that cuz everyone was I guess
there was a lot of people desperate for
Content yeah so juicers we're back
desperate for us anyway ninja go
ahead no one should no one no this might
be inappropriate and stop me but is she
wearing a bra I can't
tell uh well she's double layered so it
is hard to tell but that's also yeah
it's not super appropriate it's not he
brought it up though yeah
I'm it's not usually something I ask
uh about women just for the it's real
simple guys it's real simple the company
I work for took away our paid holidays
this year and we complained on our fake
Facebook website and the higher reps
removed the post God Bless America oh
how do you do that how do you just take
away like in in America most people get
so little time off like there is no
minimum guarantee of holidays period and
a lot of people they don't get how
the
how you expect people to live no breaks
yeah I don't know I don't know no
breaks that's
crazy and it's not funny when I was
working in Israel full-time there was
like a man mandatory the minimum was
seven days which isn't a lot think but
they also had like 10 days or something
such that was mandatory holidays times
off yeah I think it's pretty standard uh
in most of Europe as well to have
several 17 days out of 365 is not a lot
you know but you know what's even less
than 17
zero most people get Christmas off
generous if their boss is generous like
me okay go ahead ninja I put this off
for too
long can we get can we cue that music
give me some of that jumping music all
right so you want to do a little you
want who bro we know how to do it come
on
[Music]
[Applause]
dude love says ninja averaged 13,000
viewers that stream who's paying him
Where's My Money game Square game Square
what's up where's game square at I don't
know what game square is but I don't
know what game square is but I'll learn
if you pay me Square nobody wants to pay
me nobody cares poor Ethan clown
poor broke Ethan Klein yeah poor guy I I
guess I just don't understand the
industry you know
ninja he was hot he was hot five years
ago but we're not doing exclusive he's
not hot like exclusive live stream New
Year could be a well behaved little boy
we would probably have more ass bro
since I got this butt that's not
you yeah people have they don't have
goldfish memories remember two years
ago I assume sucks cuz right before we
got the button I feel like was when
people really started bailing after the
Ben ofo won that's why we got it which
that's why we got it yeah exactly which
actually speaking of that let me watch
the man do his floss Jesus and
then we I'll talk about Benny
boy I'm sorry man but aown my whole
chat's moving man I'll take it man he
should not have done that nobody did it
with him
again the whole thing wa did he were
people supposed to do it with him
not even his wife just before this
happens they all come out and surprise
him say I'm not seeing enough movement
everybody says that and then nobody else
moves when he does it hold on he's me go
back he's sponsored by State Farm and
State Farm Insurance and the pizza place
what dominoes Domino's yeah I saw that
too everything in one stream Fu I
guarantee that man is not selling any
pies you want to self pies come to the
H3 podcast yep dude I will we'll sell
pies I'll push pepperoni out to we'll
eat pizza on every episode guarantee it
he has no pizza experience I'll be like
hey guys two for one two larges with one
topping for the price of one right now
at dominoes everybody call you know many
pizzas people would be you know many
pizzas we
[Music]
sell yeah that his NFL video did crazy
16 million but I feel I don't put that
on him that's the meme that that was the
strength of the meme this is not a ninja
experience
you know but there would be no meme
without
ninja okay well there'd be no world
God yeah this is getting into the
existential again Zach is freaking
out Dan cool it listen that the
existence of ninja precedes the essence
of the meme that flows from okay but
like memes just if somebody's a meme
doesn't mean that they're a cultural
like phenomenon that deserves to have
pepperoni sponsors ninja has that right
that right combination of traits that
make it funny for somebody to sing a
song about imagining him getting a low
taper fade you got it would you can't
swap ninja out for somebody else if
Trump had a low tapered fade that's
funny that is really fun yeah I mean
that is because what if that would be
crazy what if Trump had a low taper F he
would get a low tapered fade It's Not
Unusual but Donald Trump or the pope but
that I think that's the thing the fact
that ninja did get it is part of what
makes the M wor Trump wouldn't get that
so it's that would be a really a good
question then yeah n we know the answer
you got Adam Eve and Tyler bevens
MH right we love them they they' they're
the Genesis truly it's a
snake Okay let me see this did you guys
make this is
ridiculous look at all these people all
these people who are spending their New
Year's Eve night not with their loved
ones not with their family not with
their kids but with Ninja bevens
hell yeah like how is this worth 13,000
views live views and he's making
everyone else wear that dumb t-shirt
yeah he's I don't see him in that
t-shirt uhuh even his wife is
sporting it not him has a shirt on dude
Roby K dude it's ridiculous
man I'm not supposed to do anything
right actually is his personality even
that good no no right he's good at
fortnite he became famous cuz he kind of
was
toxic now he lost that so not even funny
anymore he doesn't have like a great
personality to be hosting you guys are
hating I don't watch Ninja I don't watch
Ninja so if you guys want to defend him
I think he keeps good energy for how
long he streams and he's I know he's
professional he hasn't been canceled for
anything so Brands like him but I I
think his personality isn't bad I mean
it's not
they're Gamers you know what I mean
like yeah I guess he's silly he's silly
sometimes Ninja's number one defender in
this room is being awfully quiet right
now yeah what's going on that's Ian
right
uhuh does he have a good personality
Ian no but that's why it's funny that's
the whole point yeah I was trying to
express ear okay but like if it's like
an inside joke for you why the is
he hosting a New Year's time New Year's
Eve party with like a two dozen people
that are torn from their loved ones to
work on this Unholy event that's why
it's good like because like why does he
have 30 people standing there this is
why he's the best in the no sense and
that's why it's funny he realizes it uh
I don't think it's necessarily
intentional that's why he's funny this
picture is amazing this was one
of the last times to try to get myself
a wait this is real this isn't fake I
was wearing a hat on the show you did
that oh my God you did that to yourself
This is a screenshot from the show when
we were still over
Zoom oh
I yeah you you should you know how some
people like felons can't own guns you
should not be able to own a ra a buzzer
yeah um back to that don't change the
screen at all something I want to point
out that that speaks to what Ian was
just saying there 30 people here why is
one of the people ninja look at the guy
on the far
right that looks like ninja that's ninja
it has to be his brother so who's on the
couch wait do you think they're actually
related yeah I mean that's ninja that's
Tyler on the cou does he have a brother
Google it yeah his brother it's New Year
it's New Year music are you guys going
to do with me yeah he does he has two
brothers does everyone know how to do it
he says everybody's going to do it with
me no
some people are saying no lots of people
are saying I am not
flossing like I'm humiliated enough just
to be here brother I'm not going to
floss on I'm not flossing with you even
if it's only 13,000 people it's real
simple guys it's real simple can we can
we C that music give me some of that
jumping music all right so you want to
do little after everything you're really
going to come out and do this come on
dude I'm not I'm not feeling yeah d
makes me
feel does anyone else feel icky seeing
him
floss yeah yeah gives me like Shivers
his brother actually looks more than
than he looks more than him than him if
that makes sense yeah so that is his
brother yeah the guy in the middle is
Niya I feel like you know he looks more
like n
than there it is okay so shout out to
the
family yeah so Ben shapir is a little
piece of and all these uh
conservative grifters too take a look at
this we were talking about how wait is
it isn't this the clip that we said we
can't show no just don't show my clip we
can show him I want to show what he said
I'm show his joke got it the color of
your of your booty hole he he um I made
a joke sure it was inappropriate but I I
still do not apologize I felt it was a
well-made point indeed indeed that he
was platforming anti-semites
that were basically had a vested
interest in Ben not being alive well SP
well you know down the road right uhhuh
and so thank you Ben and so I made I
made an observation I said listen if
they coming for us being us being the
Jews then you know then you know you if
you go first I'm right behind you it
says you go you can go first but I'm
right behind you I said it in more
vulgar terms obviously but uh I thought
it was funny and I stand by
it however the conservative sphere blew
the up Donald Trump Jr even did
like a story about it everybody Ben
Shapiro made a video where he got on the
high horse he goes well I I don't know
about you but I would never wish death
on anyone okay now get a load of what
this little scumbags been up to on his
show so is it in the dock or do I need a
no I'm grabbing it okay get a load of
the content that this little
scumbag I don't hear a from YouTube
I don't hear from anyone else I
fully got cancelled like I still don't
have ads two years later of your
booty hole they did a cancel culture on
you all right here it is so the clip
that we got a strike for is in this edit
so you just need to be very ready to
pause it immediately as soon as you pop
up in this clip yeah I don't even think
showing it is necessarily but I'm not
I'm not going to I'm just saying it's
it's fine so it's not loading which is
nice very good very
good okay here we go here we go so
here's Benny boy refer uh let's take a
look what this little is up to
over on his dumbass
channel uh I mean I mean first of all
first person to go if God brings back
the flood from the Bible this guy is
literally same joke I made oh
oopsie and like if you're going to take
what I said seriously you just wish
death on him the same way Ben answer for
your crimes Man YouTube this man just
told a gay
man
mm
homophobic potentially
racis not I'm not going to disect that
part sure that he's going God is going
to kill him first in indeed now you tell
me people what is wrong with this and
why isn't Ben Shapiro fully cancelled
banned for a week unbelievable it only
happens to
me
yep yeah well they've uh they have
mastered the petty outrage machine and
they weaponize it and use against people
like you can't it's so lame they
are the cancel culture freaks man always
have been it's the as it's the astronaut
meme you know one more time for the
people in
back uh I mean I mean first of all first
person to go if God brings back the
flood from the Bible this guy and by the
way Ben Shapiro is religious he believes
the flood right that's that's what I was
going to say he really believes that
oh yeah that's not like a story to
Ben that's a real that's a threat of
death that is
literal absolutely someone said I had
two ads before joining the stream I
don't mean integrated I I mean like
sponsors not not from
YouTube our channel did not get
demonetized we'd be in big trouble if
that happened yeah that would be that
would be a nothing that dramatic
no uh so that's it imagine if uh Ben
Shapiro had a low taper fade that would
be something interesting to
imagine look horrible yeah yeah he's
doesn't have a good head for it well he
doesn't have a good yeah love to see it
that would work I'd love to see that one
sec I'll get on it so what's the status
on the uh death
ice Lena the lemonade the death ice the
death ice we canceled the order oh we
did cancel it yeah yeah they let us can
yeah it was going to take way too long
God I don't know why Panera wants to
with me so bad we're in a Panera
desert over here man what can you
do what can you do trying to do a youth
in Asia with
lemonade Panera and me are planning some
youth in Asia I still think you should
just start with one well I like to have
the backup in case we want to go there
but I'm never going to cuz these
won't give me right right
you ever you ever have a Four Loco no
actually those are pretty nice they it
was popular by the time I was like yeah
out of colle and in Israel which it
didn't exist there then by the time I
came back I think it was illegal it was
Outlaw most places yeah it was it's
illegal right well they just uh it's
still around but they changed the
formula it's not as crazy as it used be
so I'm that window I was not here got it
I was here was it good yeah it's crazy
right yeah I mean people kind of over
exaggerated it it was very easy to get
very up on them for sure well the
popular drink in Israel at the time and
still is is the Red Bull vodka so I mean
at the end of the day it's not that
dissimilar it's it's a bunch of caffeine
and alcohol so that's the it drink in
Israel Red Bull vodka I mean that's
popular here too for Loco let's see what
was uh 12% it was 12% back in the day
mhm I mean that's like a wine yeah so
it's like drinking wine with a lot of
energy drink along with it so why did so
were people getting like sick and like
dying and well it was very uh it
was sweet and it didn't taste like
alcohol let's put it that way it one of
those that you could just drink like
juice basically and uh
did quite a bit 120 lb female with a
very low alcohol tolerance would have an
estimated blood alcohol content of 02
after consuming just
one yeah so it's more than a glass it's
probably like two glasses a line of I'm
drunk they were banned at a few colleges
I'm seeing that's where it started
to I can definitely see people dying on
C on
yeah dumb
asses
idiots somebody said uh Ethan maybe not
getting the heart attack tea may be a
sign saying that it not working out is
the universe trying to protect you I
will get that tea you're going to Def
flood High wat God if blood if Ben
spirro wants me to die first in the
flood that's not going to stop
me
side like can I wish death on Ben if
it's like kind of like oh this is a fun
like is he being serious oh I hope he
dies first in the flood that's like a g
that's like a Death
Wish well how can I wish oh I hope the
see I can't even do it I can't even make
the joke I'm stopping myself because I
know it's trouble yeah literally you're
such a good person and we see that right
now this is a really good one cam
character development this honestly
looks like y so legit here's Ben Shapiro
with a low taper F that's a high taper
fish gross dude oh sorry he is I
like it though the high tapered is more
extreme should I get a high tapered fade
I would do low cuz I want it to look
silly for the show you could get May
looks fire like a super high one all the
way up here at the point where I just
have like a little island of hair just
right here at the front of your forehead
why is nobody ever talking about the mid
taper oh it's always high taper this low
tape for
that yeah
true I still want you to get the fro
back bring back the fro dude wait this
is a this was a definitely a fade oh for
sure yeah yeah there you go even got the
line and everything I remember people
liked it the
food some sisters girl you are
killing it girl let's get Glam yes she
is look at her she is slay Nation mhm
man that another lifetime Ago by now the
whole friend these are that's like three
three four years ago crazy four years
I'm still
standing that's me every morning wow
you're a big Elton John fan aren't you
yeah I like Elton you happy about his
egot his Ot Ot he has achieved that
status now got the OT what's that egot
Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony oh he did well of
course he did he's he is when you say
goat people throw that around a lot I
mean Elton is the goat he's the ego goat
he's he's the ego I mean there's not
many that do it like him for sure did he
just recently get it or something oh he
did what was the LA what what trophy did
he what just happened the Emmys it was
it was the Emmy yeah okay that man is
still out there touring like and looking
great 76 no he stopped
touring as he
didn't he just do he always he says that
every year as he claimed no yeah never
believe a musician when they say they're
retiring it's never that's what
Oliver tree says every goddamn time yep
650 million he's worth not
surprised that man crushes such a talent
love
him Crocodile
Rock did you like the
movie uh I don't I I hate bi myopics or
whatever I I biopics I can't stand these
dumb biopics I'm out I'm done it
wasn't terrible I mean I think it added
a different type of flavor to
it I didn't even know that happened
Rocket Man at
2019 like I'm I'm done with this
like the Elvis one like it's just it's
so masturbatory and it's always like one
actor who's taking on the role of their
lifetime it's like no it's not it's
not it's you know I hate it it's the
worst genre of films I don't know why it
bothers me so much you ever see the
doors is that a biopic yeah Val
Kilmer uh I think maybe a long time ago
yeah long time
ago Zack does a really good
impersonation of uh Tom hanks's
character in that Elvis movie dude what
the oh current
yeah snowman scary look at Val he look
he looks more like Jim morison than
Jim morison Val well not not now
how old is Val he's sick um he's sick
yeah he's sick oh there's this really
sad documentary I think Zach actually
told me about it what's he sick with I
forgot what exactly but his voice is
completely gone oh no he was great young
vilmer crushed it stud oh he had
throat cancer in 2015 so he's he's
cancer free but he's Thro gut yeah PL
he's cancer free he was recently in a mo
or I guess recently my life is wait hold
on that's that's Jeff Bridges
that ain't Valk
Kilmer what that's
crazy okay all
right we love them don't
we
we love that comr here on the H3 podcast
do uh let's see Oliver tree speaking of
this
scumbag he's out on the road as you guys
know he always calls in
and can't shut the up about it but
to make matters even worse here he is in
Germany Berlin of all
places out there in Germany trying to
smear my
name did somebody say something
I can't even understand with those thick
German accents I don't know what you're
saying you did you guys just say
Ethan
[Applause]
clown guy sucks man hate
that guy he's my arch nemesis I can't
even believe that that guy's shitty
little podcast made it out to dumb
middle of nowhere
Berlin
all oh you guys you he
left the stage in disgrace you one more
you stupid ungrateful son of
I think what happened you I
think what happened is he was saying
Ethan Klein and the audience was
like no no no no you yep yep we
love Ethan Klein the audience he was
really in Germany
that's parent according to he
who was on stage in Germany having
trying to get a bunch of people to say
a Jewish guy yeah wow that's what
happened
wow at a time with Rising anti-Semitism
you really want to put that out there
Oliver okay under red lights too under
red lights
Jesus what's the red light thing just CU
it looks doomy or is it pro reiky it
looks Rey reichy okay yeah it looks a
little reichy this man has no no Reich
he's got no Riz no Reich you have no
right what a
[Applause]
scumbag he want he he wants us to come
I'm assuming everybody wants to go to
the show right yeah I mean we've told
him yeah how many times I told him
11 I told him 11 that's everybody right
yeah he said that would be like 1,500
bucks oh yeah I'm not not yeah I'm not
paying for it that's for sure not paying
for that I wouldn't even PID like I
wouldn't even pay what like 30 bucks I
don't know probably charge a lot more
than that scam artist I'll check group
on
yeah anyway that's all tree you guys had
a lot to say about the Coachella lineup
I'm not really in tune with the music
world so didn't really doesn't say
anything to me because I usually don't
know who most of these people are
however lots of
disgruntled uh people here we are not
loving the Coachella lineup thoughts I
want to go you're in oh yeah it's pretty
weak so I'm I don't know Lana
Del re I mean I know the name she's
she's she a big deal she's a big deal
deal yeah yeah I mean the headliners are
all big dojacat seems we I don't know
they oftentimes will have like two
really big people and then one
mediumsized headliner that's like seen
as on the come up I don't think she's
really seen on the come up anymore
though do mad her and she was like
on her fans and all that I'm
out on Doo yeah um no doubt I'm so
excited I grew up listening to
No Doubt listen me too but um she ain't
a girl no more just a girl stop no no
doubt that that's not GNA be very good
no doubt I think it'll be great actually
yeah I like no
doubt I can't believe she's 56 I had no
idea until this morning when we were
talking about it this might sound rude
but I thought she was older really I
haven't seen pictures of her recently
she's been around forever dude I saw
people online going wild over hatsun
miku's playing yo international pop
sensation hatsun Miku play a video
yeah hey guys here's a video it's so
much more than a video Ethan it's a
hologram little Uzi vert's big that's
GNA be sick your buddy that' be cool my
is he might yeah we're
dogs Tyler the Creator I feel like he
headlines every Festival now like no
offense he's very talented and I'm a big
fan of his music but I feel like
whenever they can't find someone else to
headline they just put they just throw
Tyler the crater up there and he's
deserving of the headline but I mean at
a certain point you know want to see
other
people somebody was this you Dan Sublime
is top billing that can top build
Sublime essentially cover
band in the top row I found out that the
singer somebody said is his son yeah
okay still not him though well it used
to be Sublime with Rome whatever the
that was yeah with Rome
dude you know Rome yeah DOA cat I don't
know about all that doa's going to
it up I feel like she's going to go out
there and just like ruin
everything on
purpose I like that the sublime cover
band is build higher than Grimes though
kind of makes me feel good you hate
Grimes well she she procreated with the
devil mhm right you
know yeah yeah I saw grime in
201 how was she I'll bet you she was
better then than she will be this year
her concerts look pretty cool she has
really cool visuals mhm and she does the
Beats on stage yeah no I always liked
her I'm reading the top billing I I I
honestly don't know 90 almost none of
them I don't know any of these
people but uh that's just me that's just
me in my life you know
so okay I guess you won't be going to
Coachella this year I mean Ian what are
your thoughts you you're the music guy
you had stuff to say about this uh I
think it's pretty boring um as you said
Tyler has his own Festival in La he does
every single year where he's the
headliner right you could see him every
November here in La so right dojacat you
know I'm not really into her if I wanted
to skip her said I don't looking at that
lineup I don't know where I'm going like
usually they have something cool on a
State little yachty maybe I I mean I
don't know there's there's just not a
lot I don't think it's very interesting
but no doubt blur is cool listen I I'm a
big blur head but they're a little
they're a little past the prime too I'd
rather see gorill I'd rather see
gorillas let's put it that way G last
year and it was a good show so yeah I'll
tell you what the only thing blurry
about this is the
value yeah yeah I've never been to coach
and I don't I don't think I'll ever go
maybe maybe if the boys were one day
like Dad come to us come with us then
maybe I'd go there was also a big rumor
that Taylor Swift was going to play it
so a bunch of like swifties were buying
up tickets a few months ago so oh I feel
like it's going to flood the resale
Market
with anymore oops now that would have
been a headline she is it she is
everything she is the moment
that is Tay Tay with a capital t two of
them all right there it is
Coachella Matt Pat we found out who's
retiring from YouTube and it's a good
thing he is because this discovery would
have derailed his career I'm sure after
spending an Unholy amount of time trying
to type one single sentence I needed to
uh take a break at the facilities and uh
I'm not really sure who this one was
more Awkward for me or the film crew
made up of our employees waiting on the
other side of the door I'll say that it
poked in places that I didn't expect it
to poke and I was very concerned about
the Hefty size of the nails scooping up
some toilet water as I was going
is a front
wiper scooping up toilet water if you're
back wiping you're not sitting period
it's not a full confirmation but I I
yeah what's who scooping wait you think
most people who are back wipers they
sit I don't get the Logistics of that
did you just lift your Chic slightly
this is a major disgusting I feel like I
feel like the issue is going too low no
matter what you're under the balls I
don't think yeah I don't think thiss
anything hold on I picked up on the
implication there too a little bit but I
wouldn't say that's 100% confirmed let
me watch expected to poke and I was very
concerned about the Hefty size of the
nails scooping up some toilet water as I
was going in for the old wife scooping
up toilet water he just described
it so but if you're you doing a scooping
action from the back cuz you definitely
scoop when you're yeah yeah no you scoop
either way yeah I don't think this
Scoops happening yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know back wiping just
does not and I don't know if we'll ever
know Zach my boy it doesn't make sense
he converted you were the one that
converted Zach is that right it doesn't
it doesn't make any sense and Z
done both exactly how can you say
doesn't make any sense you did it for
like over 20 years
look you know I'm going through a big
existential crisis right now keep saying
that yeah so just let me be me right now
dude and embrace that front wiping is
the greatest thing to happen to humans
I'm glad that you're happy I don't it's
fine that you're happy it's good even
that you're happy but you're saying it
doesn't make sense does not make any any
it doesn't make sense to me either
there's no way you can properly clean
your butthole from the back no I don't
believe and Zach see I've never I've
never been a back wiper so I can't I
don't have the unique experience that
you have a bank to compare but I don't
get it yeah just it doesn't make sense
under the balls people that's the way to
travel Amen brother and you do not get
just anyone oh you get on your
balls no you do not get on
your balls or you have to cup your balls
there you go that's annoying I can hold
my phone while wiping C I usually have
to cut true right I can hold my phone
while procedure okay well I want a clean
butthole I get a clean butle that's a
good point when you're doing it from the
front you're on your phone getting two
hands down in there in the nether region
two hands that is crazy like your
is if you're cleaning with one hand I
sorry but you have a dirty shame
on you it's just because I don't have to
cup my ball sack look all I'm saying is
I think Ethan and I have the cleanest
asses in this room no question no
question you don't know no question
about it AB has something to say about
that huh I doubt that but I was going to
say grabbing your balls in general like
it's just you're just adding nastiness
to another part like I don't want those
my balls are probably one of the
cleanest things on my body I shower I
put on underwear nothing that's yeah I
mean you there's clean off after the
fact talking about the efficacy of the
method that's a little neurotic Zach I
just found out I'm half ISM so I mean
that makes sense well I don't even grow
that much hair yet dog so take that you
shower twice a day Zach yeah does that
not make your like dry you out and stuff
yeah no you use soap and shampoo every
time or no uh shampoo like the first
shower usually the nighttime
shower it doesn't dry no I feel like I
would get I would get so I SK would get
crazy if I showered twice use good soaps
use uh you know good conditioner things
of that nature oh moisturized are you
implying that I use products not at
all using that I'm
kidding good for you keep it clean I
actually like your shampoo Ethan when I
stayed in the pool house that I don't
know what's out there there was like
this slightly thicker uh Dove shampoo or
a body wash okay I was like what the
is that I had to before I left the
pool house I took a picture of it you
using it still you do you use the same
thing for hair and body no I have a Dove
so the dove it's Dove shampoo cuz you
didn't you say it's body wash the one I
like is body wash it's very thick and
it's super easy to just ladder is that
the dove for men or is it the white one
it's the white one it's probably
technically for women but I like this
smell well Matt Pat I guess the verdict
is still out if you are want to give us
an answer I'd be willing to uh talk to
about it or just
to read if you just want to say yes on
front or back that'd be good but he
definitely has a clean ass if he's
scooping yeah then he's if he's got a
clean ass and he's scooping he's going
under the balls you could eat a four
actually never mind I'm not going to say
that you could go ahead Zach I was going
to say you could you could eat off you
could eat a four course meal off his
ass yeah and I'm
sure I'm sure many would like
to didn't realize we're going to do the
chef the chef pre a prefix menu
on
uh Matt Pat's there you
go that's right front wipers have dirty
gues Shel said that's a myth only back
wipers say that kind of dumb you're
just not enlightened I'm just saying
don't as far away from the it
doesn't get anywhere close to my balls
what do you think happens there's like a
pretty good distance in terms of wiping
like wiping is a pretty precise art for
the most part mhm there's no but just
like I don't know getting your you
shouldn't get your balls involved I feel
like I feel like it's not
necessary it is necessary if you go from
the front which is God's way amen it's
not God invented a butthole and a
scooper and balls to
lift that's why you have two
hands um all
right yeah my son is a back wiper I
never even T yeah I mean he just I think
it's just a natural thing it is natural
yeah like I've never thought about it he
just he's just he's a back wiper you
know it's like right-handed left-handed
thing right yeah Wonder but similar
proportions be interesting and he's seen
me poop tons of times okay so he knows
cuz I whenever I poop I close the door
but they could always open it and
with me
okay
every time that' give me anxiety well
there do your kid you got locks yeah no
I the locks don't work like it just
doesn't get that fixed you click it and
it goes down like it's locked but it
just does nothing oh no that's
cursed I feel like every bathroom in
most bathrooms for whatever reason I
feel like the lock doesn't work at at
home your own that's the first thing I'm
fixing whenever I move somewhere it's
not
working
um but yeah so he's he's he knows that
that I'm a front wiper but uh he he's
chosen his own path in
life you know that's good it's good that
you're letting him all you can do Forge
his own path life absolutely yeah uh
myin from fresh and fit is cringey
little weirdo which we all knew
but here he is this was on New Year's
Eve this dude thought he was posting a
dub he he willingly put this on the
internet he says 63 200 lb 33 years old
and it's midnight on New York Eve
weekend in Miami while everyone parties
I work this is why I can tell hoes
losers and fat to shut the f up
get your ass in a gym make more money
and start becoming Superior to these
normies competence leads to
accomplishments which then gives you
confidence are you ever going to talk
about being a lonely loser like there's
nobody in the world that would look at
this and think this is a dub You Are by
yourself on a holiday that's meant to be
enjoyed with others like this this is
this
is this is beyond sad yeah it's pretty
bad it's even sadder that he wrote all
of that took that photo and still didn't
realize that it could have been
perceived as as he posted that yeah
I guess he was probably just like I he
was probably feeling depressed that
nobody want to be with them on New York
Eve and that is depressing especially as
he said 33y old
man
successful yet nobody wants to
spend that holiday with him like that is
depressing he's coping and he's coping
yeah for sure but he didn't realize what
an obvious cope it is female vaginas are
disgusting it's like poetry on the
timeline why are you and then didn't he
post this around midnight or 9:30 p.m.
like that's not even like why are you in
the gym at 9:30 but that's time it would
have been it would have been 30 minutes
after midnight okay cuz I remember it
being like right around midnight yeah
yeah so you're telling me that as
fireworks are going off and everybody's
celebrating getting their getting that a
kiss and all this kinds of stuff you're
in the gym by yourself mad as hell
coping super funny you're doing great
bro so now that I'm up you down you're
doing great bro that the
happiness is oozing off the photo the
success I see it dude can you imagine a
security guard like seeing this like a
dude alone in the gym takes his shirt
off takes a picture you good security
guard there's no like looking at the
tapes why is this open someone working
in the building at the time it looks
like a hotel gym or something like it
it's probably apartment building Oh
apartment building gym Halo
nobody's there myin and it's not cuz
they don't work hard it's cuz they're
not pathetic lonely losers
do we think subliminally he was posting
it because he wanted people in the
comments to wish him a happy New Year
nobody yeah I don't think that's what
happened though if I to guess I mean
here let's look notice how all the
haters are not men oh wow oh that's him
that's him responding to himself yeah
yeah okay notice how all the haters are
not men you aspire to be like or
hate always comes from below interesting
I mean how do you define how do you
define
what do you mean men you'd want to be
like I feel like you could just say that
about anyone you
know you want you know I mean
listen I'm to tell you man sad you're
choosing to ignore your religion's
teachings you claim that part of
masculinity is being religious and
traditional you have to practice what
you preach so we can take your word
seriously masculinity is not just going
to the gym myON just follow your myin
just follow your father and mother
religious beliefs and don't ignore the
teaching of Islam by Sleeping with women
and following your desire you know that
is Haram and you're contributing to the
problems you are an example of the youth
you an example for the Youth don't make
it worse so he's getting it from all
over the place the
religious uh the conser I assume that
you know if you're a
religious Muslim you're probably more
conservative the libs definitely aren't
going to like this I don't think anybody
is admiring you not one person actually
The only positive comment is you left it
on your own
post what a loser you what a
loser this dude
is can you suck your own dick
yet interesting question why are you
posting a picture are you a woman oo a
good oh no hey this side sucks ass man
one of your pecs is severely bigger than
the other the dumbest people that's
weird could just be an angle maybe one
of the comments says his face looks like
Squidward's
house yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I see it quite a bit actually
for are you allowed to be shirtless in
the
gym I I think it's not sanitary it's not
kosha right like you do progress picks
in like the bathroom yeah but maybe
that's why he's here hey this is the one
night of year no one's going to be there
so you could be a little
little little you
showing so much skin huh thirst trapping
I see you so there it is fresh and fit
who would have guessed that he's a
lonely sad loser
nobody not a single
soul George Santos oh my God this guy's
story is
bananas now that he's been uh removed
from
uh
Congress he's basically just mask off uh
embracing what a creepy weirdo
he is and people love it I love it
actually he's a sassy
I would talk to him can we get him
on the show I can try yeah let's get him
on the show I think we have we have
reached out and we haven't heard back
but I will now he yeah he his his
schedule is a lot more open maybe
cleared a bit him up on Cameo
exactly we watch that whole thing we'll
okay good good go ahead Georgie Georgio
Orman what could we do to get you to go
away stop inviting me to your
gigs so no Dancing with the Stars no no
rupal's drag Grace I haven't got that
invite yet i' love to go read
a the lesson is to stop inviting you
places but you can't cuz people want the
content dude he such a nihilistic like
he
has this man doesn't care about anything
he's psycho it's crazy it's kind of
awesome though I much prefer like brutal
radical
honest George than well I would call him
honest I guess he's being honest right
there but well The Jig Is up I don't
think this man no I don't know like
nobody's given him money for a dog
charity or anything like that anytime
soon people only focus the fraud aspect
of this guy but forget his contributions
in exposing the moral rot in society um
he there's plenty of people still doing
that he's he's far from unique in that
do one without the other yeah so there
he is we'll stop talking about him I'll
do my duty
unless he of course wants to call to the
show which L is a standing invite so it
sounds like sounds like you're saying
yes you're right George and also of
course he's right of course he's right
you want the content
yeah but the good thing is that he's in
his case in his case I kind of agree I
don't know what to say the guy is he's a
born Entertainer should have gone into
politics or or scamming he should have
gone into ENT that's where he's going
now you know but he's harmless in the
sense that nobody's he's not doing any
scams anymore cuz nobody trusts him
here's here's a Squidward's
house wow weirdly
Works New York or New Year's Eve
2023 the location Squidward's
house inside one lonely
man thank you speaking of SpongeBob a
new photo just
dropped yeah I saw this a little
weird here is SpongeBob the actor wait
that is that not edited why does his eye
look like that but why what is wrong
with his
face this is like AI or something this
can't be real is this real wait it has
it is AI yeah this look at the or no
it's blink I that's real yeah it's a
blink but then why is the that's a
corset but where's his other eye he's
blinking like he's blinking just like
the like his corset where's his other
eye coret he's winking just
likeing he's winking it's a weird wink
brother look like he has a black eye all
right there it
is a cran smed him right in his
head uh brain like couldn't process that
image that was weird David
dubri uh tea being spilled by Jason
friends I think
um I think there might be a riff
starting to form because Jason as we've
pointed out is his new full-time job is
begging for donations on Tik Tok which
is quite sad for a man uh of his age and
and he has kids yeah
Prestige listen to
this it like the thing is like David's
in this like moment in his life yeah
where he can do anything where he just
parties like every day like genuinely if
there was a party every day jay he would
be at it not kidding yeah and he
remember he doesn't
drink I've never dude I'm telling you
people who go I just don't drink I never
drink for no reason Trump's one of those
people that's I'm telling you these
people are all they're not good
people just be aware of them keep an eye
on them people who say that
was another person like I just don't
drink for no reason like okay it is
interesting that he goes out all the
time and he doesn't drink at all and he
films drunk people that's his life
that's like the least fun thing to do
ever is to be surrounded by drunk people
and be absolutely so true so true so
true do we like does he drinking having
does he uh say no to all drugs is he a d
kid or is he just drinking from what I
understand he's a d kid but I could be
wrong cuz how the you going to
parties every night and not doing
trugs uh yeah I'm not sure I'm I'm
looking into it
now a good time whatever I just can't do
that man you know no I can't either I
just can't do that and like I'm not not
like you have the option
buddy he's like no I wouldn't want to do
that I wouldn't want to make millions of
dollars a month and go party all the
time that's just not for
me yeah I'm sure you wouldn't do that I
prefer to just you know beg for money on
Tik
Tok he has something to celebrate cuz
he's made it yeah you know we talked
about this before I can't put myself in
that mindset like yeah he calls me to
play pool and I'm like I got to go live
and and I don't and I don't expect him
to understand that like I I know I've
told him there's also things that I like
say to him and I'm not sure if he hears
me he doesn't like I'll say things like
I'm losing my house and he'll be like oh
but just come play
pool it's not that funny sounds like a
horrible person sad that's so sad I like
that they're all just like that's David
no he's a horrible friend like Jason he
should have set you up
nice after everything you guys have been
through I don't know what or how but you
should be rich you should be rich too
the fact that you're like I got to do
hours on Tik Tok to pay my
bills that's
nuts there was a great T Tok that he
sent which was like some guy I don't
know if you saw it he sent it to me it's
just like a Tik Tok and it's just a guy
on the phone and it's it's basically
David he's like yeah it's just the guy
that has like a lot of money and can't
and can do anything all day he's like oh
Dipple is having a party tonight and
like it's literally like things that
David has said I mean it's crazy four
Diplo is a freak too from what I
understand partying with Diplo I
wouldn't want to do that I wouldn't by
the
way here's SpongeBob's Neighborhood this
is a cool
alternative uh setting
and there's a coconut on the left
coconut this is cool man I like this
remake this is a great Vibe
yeah that's a good one okay I like that
I like that go go on Jason I mean but if
you think about it though from 18 to
like what 23 24 oh he was H he he never
he never drank I don't think he ever
drank never did anything oh so it sounds
like he did start drinking I just
remembered he would like even when we
um visit him we'd be up to like midnight
just like watching the edits just like
hey is this is this part better or this
one's better yeah yeah yeah and then he
would have everyone just crowd around
his bed I just remember that I was like
I thought that was insane and and that
and now it's like the complete opposite
everyone's like working and hears him
just like hey what are you doing tonight
it's like a Tuesday night everyone's
working you want to watch a movie yeah
it's just a crazy switch honestly m but
I just I mean I just can't I just I mean
the guy the guy work J is so bitter hard
as he should be you know for four years
you were there yep I mean you lived like
eight lives honestly Jason I know and
that that YouTuber time is so
um you do so much in such a little
amount of time like I don't know you're
like doing so much yeah meaning like in
one day you know you're at a ranch
shooting you're at uh freaking Madison
Beer's apartment shooting you know what
I mean you're just like just do so much
in just a little amount of time yeah and
were you paid for all that no were you
compensated in any way uhuh for a full
day of work fully dedicated to
David do brook who's now basically
retired off the money no what is wrong
with these
people God
damn I missed the I missed the podcast I
wish he I missed the money of the
podcast I see Jason say this on a Tik
Tok ah he was doing the views thing I
don't think that podcast was long for
this world regardless
of who knows what kind of fell apart
when the his whole life fell apart so
yeah
oops was awesome not that it happened
but just that
know clip like every other week he
turned down $10 million I you say that
on like Tik Tok Clips all the time yeah
yeah yeah that's like that's that's like
a joke for my act that I say which is
you know he turned down all this money
and all he had to do was talk to me once
a week for 40 minutes you know like
um I'll tell you why it stings is
because that's that's literally every
comment on Tik Tok live okay but like
you're ignoring the fact that his whole
life was like upended after these essay
allegations it wasn't like he just
stepped away cuz he's like Jerry
Seinfeld or something like stepping away
in his prime no there was nobody
sponsoring that show anytime
soon it's looking like they did five
episodes before everything came out
let's see yeah I remember I me yeah
there was decent views on them but P
these kinds of podcasts always come out
of the gate really strong I mean this is
two years on too so it's I'm sure it's
gone up
but I remember this Diplo one didn't
have a lot of views
cuz nobody cares about Diplo
loser is a
weirdo I don't remember why but I just I
remember you
just bad vibes
yeah
definitely when's the podcast coming
back so that's why it stings cuz it's
like if no one cared I'd be like oh
whatever no that was the best podcast
ever it was
fun um and you were great on it when you
would come on thanks he this this is so
sad yeah it's like this is rough this is
just the hey remember the good days
they're
reminiscing this is the podcast where we
just sadly reminisce about when life
didn't stck for
us when David let us suck from his
tit he would always drag you in there
and you'd be like I got to
work he fire you up it is crazy how like
no matter how many people love it around
him if he doesn't love it he just won't
do it by the way shout out to my boy
here keeping
it time uh time appropriate juicy thigh
shot boy fat juicy thigh
shot absolutely put two hamburger buns
on either side of that and take a bite
MH that's a beefy Patty
yummy
lunchtime how many people love it around
I just I love that the Bros are just
showing leg like this this is the new
Alpha thing like just showing as much
thy as you can without your balls coming
out it's awesome it's so it's so
straight so masculine if he doesn't love
it he just won't do it yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and which
is totally fair yeah yeah I think so
which is like if you're not into it
that's why I don't I don't bring it up
or whatever it is a crazy concept
because you give that concept to anybody
else and they're like
what what concept two people talking
what are you talking about pretend
million yeah oh my
God all you have to do is literally go
from your bedroom to your downstairs
pantry and talk for 40 minutes for $10
million why dude he was like brutally
cancelled that's why he what the
are we doing here they're making it
sound like $10 million offer on the
table somehow I doubt that it's possible
he had like that much sponsorships lined
up over like the course of a year
maybe that's I mean that's a lot that's
a lot that is a lot lot lot lot
so they kind of casually threw that
figure out there it's said eyebrow
raising Jason he was going to get a
piece of that 10 million and now he's
just begging for money God that's what
all the headlines were saying that Jeff
was suing for 10
million just funny that's the same
amount Jeff's Coming For That podcast
money je coming one loves you yeah yeah
yeah yeah well that's not the case not
everyone loves you there's a lot of
there's a lot of people true but I'm
just saying generally the people that
listen yeah generally the people that
listen yeah yeah love you know yeah yeah
yeah General me too I could say it about
in general the people like
me there are dedicated hate groups
though and we love them too cuz they're
loyal
fans frankly Diplo accused of disturbing
Revenge PW word dude I'm telling you
this guy is all bad all bad vibes what
is this Diplo accused of Distributing
Revenge pord the woman who has been
entangled in a legal battle with the
artist since 2020 claimed Diplo
distributed new phes of her without her
consent
okay I thought there was more stuff than
this I mean lot yeah a lot of people in
chat are saying that he has a bunch of
allegations that's what I thought yeah
it's Diplo
bro
Diplo the only the only one of these DJs
that I with is my boy shout out to
the family that guy seems like such a
genuine David guda
cheese that man keeps it real every day
of his
life shout out
to we love it okay so that's the D
te
interesting always nice to check in
although these days it's just checking
in on how pathetic and sad Jason's life
has become
Jesus um I have good
news Googled David Gua uh
allegations zip and the top result about
allegations that he faked his live shows
zip so if that is the worst thing he's
been accused of he's a good man I could
tell shout out to his family shout out
to his family dude oh this was this is
new te Tana drags Jason okay Jason Nash
a door Dash account if I open my
Tik Tok one more time to seeing him
begging for roses on my live for you
page I'm calling CPS have you seen your
kids have you seen them and also when
they go to school are their friends like
hey I saw your dad like begging for a
Galaxy like and I'm I know I'm a sellout
okay I'm not against people doing things
for money but at this point it's like I
would rather see him behind a pay wall
cheeked up like I just I just don't get
I just every single time I've opened my
phone Jason Ash is on live begging for
money and I want answers have you seen
your kids this
month she's not wrong she's not wrong
I've noticed that too girl speaking of
um Jason Nash actually he's part of the
neighborhood too I didn't
realize oh wow it's the Cinematic
Universe I just want to complete it yeah
that's a that's a we need a uh Patrick I
believe we need a Gary right and we need
a Squidward too I guess true we have his
house yeah but not
him that's awesome that's great love
that so
good
um there it
is listen to the Super Chat when ninja
was a pro Halo player I asked him to
sign some merch he said after you take a
picture of my family and I took it and
then he left dot dot dot see that's
that's funny wait hold on hold on hold
on read that again what happened when
ninja was a pro Halo player which is
that's where he got to start he wasn't
all that then he was under I think he
was pretty small before fortnite yeah
yeah no yeah nothing to that level but
when he was a pro Halo player I asked
him to signed some merch he said after
you take a picture of my family I took
the picture and then he left so he asked
the fan to take a picture of him yeah I
guess maybe he was there with his family
and he said thanks man just walked away
I could see that being a slip of the
mind yeah you know no I'm not going to
hold it against him
yeah we foron mistake I'm sure we
forgive him
yeah we do yeah let it go Aaron let it
time to Let It Go go
bro uh
Colleen who cares about Colleen anymore
she says stories that came out about her
lies being the reason why she didn't get
a role in
Broadway yeah I'm sure think so that's
an interesting way to put it I guess go
ahead girl speak your mind last year was
um me saying oh I'm about to go do this
big audition I've been talking about it
for like I think weeks or months maybe
even at that point and I finally went
and I did the audition and that was
where we left off I actually have a vlog
I think of the next day of after the
audition so let me know if you guys want
to see that or parts of it but do I I
think I do anyway I'm a little bit
sensitive about this which is why I
haven't talked about it even though you
guys have asked about it a lot but I'll
touch on it really briefly because so
many people have asked about this the
audition went really well and um I was
really excited about it it was an
audition for a Broadway show and I got
it and we you know had dates set and I
was really excited to um go do Broadway
again and um then it didn't happen and I
was Daisy's playing with my rocks Daisy
hey don't touch your rocks bro that's
personal man I know how important that
is to her she's a rock Mommy now she's a
rock mom come here but like you know
obviously a lot happened last year a lot
was said last year I lost that
opportunity um right after a story came
out about me that was just completely
made up and it is what it is and you
know we're moving forward sir shame
anyway I feel
like if she's bold enough to say that
that story that came out was a lie I
think she's bold enough to lie about
getting a part in a Broadway show you
think she maybe she auditioned and
didn't get it well she said she has
receipts okay show me cuz I don't
believe
you yeah if it okay I was doing some
reading in like the comments and people
are speculating that it was probably
Roxy heart in Chicago just because
Chicago always has people come and like
guest star and I looked and in January
the person who was in like the Scandal
thing is playing that role so I wonder
if those were the slots that Ariana
what's it oh yeah Ariana is the one
playing Roxy heart wait what
yeah which one AR it's been a while
Tom's girlfriend Ariana his long-term
girlfriend uh uh what the that
show called Chicago Vander pump rules
Vander Vander pump this
is
oh Tom's they broke up right because he
cheated on her spoiler alert spoiler
alert should we everybody's cheated
that's like the most unspoiling thing
everybody cheats on everybody this whole
show oh yeah that was the big thing he
that was the big
thing so um so button or no no why what
the I would button what get out of
here hilarious I was trying so hard to
avoid it we were me Rush rushing through
the seasons so she got the part I
actually like her she's she is she got
over bad and she never she's
actually one of the few people on the
crew that never cheated I think right
yeah she always had Good Vibes good
reputation this guy's the biggest douche
in the world get a load of this
guy oh
man yeah shout out howy
Mandel shout out cam please can you make
make coconuts and Barbados as Patrick's
house was one request and then there was
another
one that was adding to this what about
uh Mr Krabs who's Mr Krabs in this
situation this person
said oh I'm missing a lot of donuts like
Jason should be Mr Krabs because you
know money Mr Krabs loves money and I'll
Mr Krabs would do anything for for a
dollar they said Matt re as handsome
squid worth oh that's pretty good oh
that's pretty good actually he didn't
come up today everything else was like
related to the show today oh here I've
got the donations here this is nice we
got a who could ninja be let's see Ninja
should be Gary yeah I like that
yeah got Gary energy Tom Sandy ball
Sandy
Tom okay it's not
bad um I'm just I'm catching up here I
didn't get my ADHD diagnosis till I was
35 cuz I always hung up on the
hyperactive part reading more of the
symptoms was enlightening for sure I
guess I got that I don't
know I met Sean on Monday at the Oliver
tree concert he was so nice he is he is
genuinely a really nice
guy yeah can say that about him Sunday
is my 24th birthday Jen hel says Zach
it's crazy because I've been watching H3
consistency so 16 shout out eight years
that's pretty much my whole online
career day one fan I still remember
watching the first episode of the pod on
my bedro floor getting ready for school
nice love you no homo of course not
cheers my
dude yeah there was another um SpongeBob
suggestion though I think it was Ben
Shapiro with the fade as Patrick's house
so you can decide which direction I
think I'll go with that
one yeah
yeah his head is
more this is a
oh here's the explanation Dan of how
they found the
ad in case anyone is curious how I ended
up finding this I was watching an old
tunami broadcast video and I just
happened to skip around whoa and see the
commercial huh and see this commercial
and then just wow that's okay random
yeah H small world that's still such a
trip like I said I hadn't thought of
that in decades you got itly you pull
that I'm going to pull it after the
show okay yeah cuz I need that
definitely need that Mega Man has always
been a part of my
[Laughter]
life always has always will what can I
say speaking of SpongeBob Ariana wrote a
new song about uh her love interest she
says let's see I guess the lyric goes
you're kind of like a pirate song like
all the music on SpongeBob is this a
good song I haven't heard it
it's like a sea shanty yeah I like that
your business is yours mine is mine why
do you care so much whose dick I ride
that's on her new single yes and I like
it she's like okay yes I broke up their
family with a newborn
and I would avoid the topic if I was her
just not a good look yeah she lost like
350k followers after this damn that
really hurt her huh that's a
line wait after the whole SpongeBob
Fiasco or after this after the song was
released oh for real it says a mid drama
yeah I'm guessing yeah in the wake of
her new song is it a good song is it
catchy yeah it it sucks that
she seemingly sucks I love that thank
you next song it's catchy great yeah
it's a good
song Ian oh you're the you're a fan Ian
what' you think of
it um yes catch I don't know it's a fun
song you really know how to pick them
don't don't you Ian to be to be uh
publicly I think you know God she's the
worst right yeah really horrible
publicly I think can't believe she did
that yeah she's the worst frankly is
that what you think about Kanye one
might even say Wicked one literally one
might one would say that one did a fan
would say that anyway uh why do you care
so much about whose dick I ride I mean I
don't think anyone does it's just like
you always turn it into a spectacle the
Pete Davidson thing was a spectacle the
SpongeBob thing was a huge
spectacle you
know who told was it not you Olivia that
told me the update with like the wife or
something I don't there I thought there
was some update to this whole Saga I
know that page six like edited their
initial article said there's no actual
proof that Ariana separated a marriage
but the wife did go to page six and she
did give those quotes and so yeah
there's no actual like credible evidence
sure what who cares we all know what
happened but it's like no we can all
insinuate we can all infer yeah what are
we talking about um and the wife said so
so this is so good this unearth uh video
this is from golly what year is this got
to be
from he this dude says he got a
$4,500 Bounty from reporting keemstar to
the IRS for tax
fraud so awesome check this
out
keemstar I made $4,500 off of keemstar
in
2011 2011 I made
$4500 off of keemstar because I snitched
on him because he
admitted on you want to know you want to
know how I prove it hear me out cuz
everybody knows when he was part when he
was leading Federation of
Gamers he would brag that people would
pay him a lot of people a lot a lot of
people he was he bragged that he was
making about $10,000 or so a month off
of people being friends with him on Xbox
Live and he would charge people $20 a
month to be friends with him on Xbox
Live
and then he would charge them like $50 a
month for like something special so they
would like play with him like like
priority he admitted to never paying
taxes on any of that money he was
providing a service and it's
awesome uh imagine a world where people
pay to be friends with keemstar that
world is long dead man okay that
guy is one of I Poseidon's stream
snipers oh for real yeah he's from that
universe so he he's just a this dude is
just a manace yeah he's insane actually
it's good I just recog that sh was funny
yeah speaking of keemstar here's a super
rare unar one we found of him without
his hat so this is unbelievable y I
never thought guys very important I'd
see a new great five King Stars has been
suspended for 2 weeks it's suspended
until October
15th I need your help we need your
help and
promoting photo he's got to be like bald
like hoe Mandel bald you know yeah mhm
all
right how long we been going here uh 310
it's freezing in here isn't it I'm
always cold in here it's quite it's been
cold man I don't think there's been a
good temperature in here for a year is
there either warm we have a heater right
I mean yeah it's been running but too
low if you sounds like everybody's cold
if everybody's
cold let's turn up the heat let's turn
it down Cam's all about it I love it
there's a few of us who are always hot
I'm one of them you're okay so I so
there's there is a conf yeah but I don't
touch it I got I got my fan right next
to me so cuz I know it's not normal I
don't know if it's cuz I'm getting older
because I lost a bunch of weight but I'm
like cold as lately it's also
winter maybe that's why so here Here's
the final one this is bench Piro as
Patrick's house okay yeah and then this
is ninja as Gary good choice oh
fantastic
choice and what are we going to work
coconuts and Barbados in here or no we
didn't really talk about him today true
true very true this is a nice summary of
today's episode what the is this
photo of his hair spiky Patrick Patrick
he's a pin head did his hair really look
like that or did you add that okay all
right nice
yes thank you all right well let's see
if there's something to hit on real fast
here let's do
[Music]
this all right uh let's do the Stanley
Cup experiment on
Friday the Stanley Cup experiment and ab
I want to get like a bucket of hot water
I want to get like we'll do it in the
dishwasher we'll do I can we set it on
fire like legit can we just burn like
put it in a fire yeah we could buy
another
one we don't have a very easy way to do
an open flame here I suppose we could do
it in the parking lot yeah we could put
it in the air fryer or
something yeah yeah well I mean the the
yeah I mean the the the dishwasher gets
very hot I mean dishwasher I feel like
that's a good test it's a good test I
think it's going to I have this thing
ice St ice for 3 days it's crazy no way
three days what is that I'm rocking the
slim dude that's that's the what's
the brand slim oh it's just slim I don't
know if yeah that's the thenude
huh you want to put that in the washer
too we'll do a test get another one
these aren't as high yeah I'll buy you
one for the experiment I'll buy you
another one for the experiment AB cuz I
want to burn that I want to set it
on fire oh yeah let's do it we can just
get maybe like some kind of um metal
receptical put some lighter fluid and
some wood fireplace wood and just get a
fire going sure yeah I got you no
problem got inside although if there's
Rubber and stuff that's not going to be
good huh is there rubber on it like well
yeah not rubber really well it'll it's
not it's not a great thing to do to just
like talk well don't breathe
it yeah I stand what about like dipping
them in a Boiling Pot of water that's
good cuz then you won't melt anything
either it's well you can melt but also I
think that would be a lot less hot than
a
fire definitely yes yeah
mhm everybody's calling you out for
misidentifying your cup my dude me
simple modern does that ring a bell I
don't know it's ring a bellm slim slim
slm the
one simple modern shit's busting though
oh people like that one simple Mar is a
elite the one I use is
um I have
one it's really good too what is it
called everybody's like my cup's really
good yeah it's a thermos no existed for
a long time no no not revolutionary
stuff the technology is different
telling you Den you don't know what
you're
saying uh so we'll do the Stanley Cup
test on Friday as well as we I'm really
looking forward to the segment we've got
planned on Friday yes it's going to be
really
fun um we didn't talk about Ace
family oh it's two videos that we got to
get through they're long too I watched a
bit of Austin's yesterday and the thing
that was killing me is that he did it on
Snapchat and there's so many ads
oh yeah that was he's doing this
heartfelt kind of
Spiel and it's just interrupted every
like 15 seconds with the most horrific
ad you can imagine it's totally
unwatchable looks like Catherine did the
same thing angle okay that's the place
they both definitely have fat Snapchat
deals and they're fulfilling some kind
of daily quota mhm which is which
is which is you know good strategy get
it so you know when you too bad you can
only get divorced
once they get remarried maybe they get
remarried for
or maybe this is all a clout
move share something very lifechanging
with your family or your girl why she
posted like this for real come on like
it's not the right orientation it's
flipped May the whole thing like that
maybe she was shooting a YouTube video
and then she was like oh I need to make
my Snapchat quota and then upload it to
Snapchat right possibly or even the
public right even then couldn't you flip
it just add bars yeah it's really really
annoying to watch this is terrible part
of the contract might need to be that
it's full screen does she ever fix it
just skip skip ahead she doesn't whole
oh you say there might be a a full
screen agreement yeah because I know Tik
Tok for example they don't like when you
use black bars as well yeah I like it's
so much better when the whole video is
misoriented it's like almost unwashable
I got to S like this awesome not to make
this video like
so long and just I'm just trying to live
my life genuinely like I just want to
yes go back to just being myself
actually like truly being myself in my
most rawest form because I feel like I
hold a lot of things in um and I'm sure
this is going to go everywhere but I I
do want to say that and I I own I own
this I own up to this I lied to myself
for a very long time
and I was not happy all right did
anybody has there ever been a
successful family type of Vlog where the
parents weren't like divorced eventually
like the OG the
Osborne okay I mean they're not you the
OG's I feel like they're in a different
I don't know like the Shay is that
what there's her name sha tards yeah
sorry
what did you just call me yeah no their
channel name was
Shaytards shards yeah they're like the
first huge family vloggers and they're
still going this dude they're still
going oh yeah it's the main guy got like
busted their last name yes last name is
Shard it's no no it's uh J car J
Carl where are you getting that from
that's the name of their Channel Dan
jards got it so anyway the main dad got
outed by some uh apparently really
embarrassing DMS of him begging a was a
porn star trying to have sex with her
while married yeah never go full shayar
that's what they say it was really
really embarrassing
man the DMS and
everything should we pull some of those
I'm looking at them they're crazy yeah
they're I remember them being super bad
Shay Tex
yeah I mean if if it's super graphic I I
just won't read it is that bad it's yeah
B he he
says I bend over and slap my oh yeah I
oh my God and she's and she's not
responding either by the looks of it
he's like just telling stories in the DM
oh my God WR romance novels he's doing
extreme
explicit descriptions of what he would
do to her walls of text and she is not
responding I think don't show right Ian
or right Ethan asking if so vulgar I
wouldn't show it yeah it's just hideous
dude imagine you got kids and that
comes
out down bad
bro figure your
out anyway that's it that's it
we're calling it glad we got to that Ace
family
update actually Catherine's didn't have
ads how come
Austin I found a version of Austin with
no ad that's what's in the dock right
now oh so just the way it was cut well
the ads was the best part this video
sucks
otherwise he just he just Rambles on
about nothing man I put some
time says they made best friends
whatever he sniffles
sniffles that's a time stamp like that
one was a joke no one will really know
uh what her and I were going through um
is there no sniffle no one will really
know he
sniffled where was the
sniffle
back I'll open it again it no I didn't
notice a sniffle one will really know uh
what her and I were going through AB
where's the sniffle you have to say for
yourself AB I'm trying to switch too and
there's like when I'm switching to my
other input I'm hearing like six Ethan
so give me a second it's one of those
things where like I went back more no
one will really know uh what her and I
were going through um no one will that
man's air passage is
clean Austin says he may get a home in
the same neighborhood that was
interesting Ela thought that that's
creepy and weird but I I I could see it
I could see it both ways if it's like if
they really did amicably separate it I
guess it'd be nice for the kids that
have them be close mhm uh but it could
also be really creepy questions is um he
wants to buy a house in the same
neighborhood yeah how was this
guy he just had a house foreclosed on
like two years ago and they supposedly
bought this other house he's going to
buy another house I don't know I do not
understand their financial life at all
it defies all in Los Angeles logic yeah
that was another one of the theories is
that they're getting divorce so he could
claim
bankruptcy put stuff in Katherine's
name oh even the divorce is a scam
that'd be awesome I
I would root for him to pull
that off if that's really what he's
scheming because that's just that's an
epic
ass that's next level I highly there's
no way that's yeah I don't think so I
don't think so but liting situ want the
ones with the ads um I've been looking
for ads home and uh fingers crossed but
yeah whatever I may have
found um a home in the same
neighborhood yes guys I'm one of those
dads I have to be I mean that's good we
like good Dads around here if that is
really the reason why that's fine yeah I
think that's good he wants to get back
to creating content as you guys have
been seeing I've been I've been going to
church well we all been going to church
as a family
uh which is amazing oh that is nice that
they're still doing that as a family
workwise I have some plans uh that you
guys
will stay tuned
for um but you know obviously still in
the social media world I've always been
since the vine days you guys know all
right I mean they go to church
together they're going to live by each
other that theory may not be a bad
one MH may not be a bad one I'm telling
you I'm rooting for him if that's the
case pull brother the future of their
YouTube channel this is the big question
um another question you guys had is
what's going to happen with the ace
Family YouTube
channel
um well Katherine and I uh you know
we've talked about this years ago cuz
her and I both know that you know we
weren't going to be doing YouTube
Forever
um and that we always wanted for our
kids to take it over um brother children
do that you know what I
mean their attitude is like if you want
to make money from this you go do it oh
and by the way I get a cut because
that's my show the goal and obviously
now um you know in the direction that
we're going it only makes sense how are
you going to give it to your kids
they're like five that's another scam
legally they give it to their kids right
but what do they get from it well he
doesn't have to give it up when he
bankrupts or something maybe I don't
know I don't think I don't think I don't
think YouTube's considered an asset you
don't think so I mean your business
could be not a YouTube channel maybe not
I don't think so I don't know though huh
obviously no pressure onid take a
YouTube I will say but how how it's not
worth anything unless you're I mean
they'll just Garn the value I is is
inherent in the uh in the person not on
the channel itself but I don't know it's
re Revenue generating technically I mean
what's their CH their channel has like
10 million Subs I me it's a big Channel
yeah even more I think back when we were
filming um our kids loved it especially
L um I'm sure they did all right that's
all I got to say about that 18.4 million
wow how old is their oldest kid huh how
old is their oldest how old are their
kids who are now inheriting oh not old
enough to have a YouTube channel yeah
what the hell yeah you're not going to
give uh Bruce and Teddy and the third
kid h3h3 Productions I had not thought
about that you don't use it I don't see
the chronology of that lining
up pass it down like a fair family
heirloom imagine in like you
know another like five six years
Theodore he just starts posting like
Minecraft content on uh H seg I'm sure
like an 11-year-old's Minecraft Channel
I'm sure everybody will be super nice
and that'll be a really nice healthy
experience for him the oldest is
seven seven the youngest is
four or three and a half all right good
good luck out there on your YouTube
career
guys
uh that's all I have to say today that's
it so um I'll be on Howe show live
tomorrow I'm
what time he's starting before I get
there he's he asked me just to pop in I
don't know what he has planned I don't
know if it's like an event or something
he said just pop in for a bit I said
sure okay I'll be there I'm planning to
be there around 12 but I don't I don't
know what 12 Pacific he's starting
before that I know that on the dot
you'll see Ethan on how we stream
tomorrow on the dot on the dot 12:00
Pacific time I'm going to try to be
there at 12 High
Noon you should ask him how he feels
about the the Tom episode Tom
sandal I've we've talked to him about it
haven't we not on his show but have we I
don't
know we talked about it when we saw it I
don't know if we followed up with him oh
I got to talk to him about it anything
else I should ask him about he had RFK
on yeah RFK was pretty
good so you voting for him you voting
for him
how uh did you get him
yeah yep me and RFK were tight like
that the vaccines may my voice sound
like this sounds like SpongeBob's
laugh no but we kid him because he has a
real condition and we don't like to joke
about those things serious stuff um so
that's Thursday that's tomorrow on
Friday we'll be back I promise it's
going to be a banger episode fun
segments it's going to be great great
great
n uh to everybody at home have a great
evening a blessed Thursday and I will
see yall on Friday thanks
[Music]
everyone imagine
Ninja